18h10 on est en direct sur brut avec
jean luc mélenchon le président du
groupe parlementaire de la france
insoumise était avec nous il va répondre
à mes questions pour sa première
interview mais d'éthique de l'ennemi 19
mais aussi aux vôtres les commentaires
votre espace de liberté d'expression
pour réagir aux propos de jean luc
mélenchon mais aussi poser vos questions
on prendra les tendances vos
commentaires vous savez que
l'interactivité
on la met au coeur du direct et on va la
mettre encore une fois à l'épreuve
aujourd'hui avec vos commentaires merci
monsieur mélenchon c'est votre première
interview manque de l'année 2010 noël et
ça se passe donc sur brut on vous
remercie de nous avoir choisis pour
répondre à nos questions et cette
première question que j'aimerais vous
poser on a tendance à des internautes
il ya une interview de marine le pen
dans valeurs actuelles qui vous parle de
points de convergence entre la france
insoumise et le rassemblement national
nous pouvons tomber d'accord sur
certains sujets qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez vous d'abord je crois car moi
je crois pas qu'elle mme et interrogeait
donc je vais pas lui répondre je vais
vous dire ce que je ressens
bon il est habile c'est aussi une
manière de
de me mettre dans l'embarras parce que
tout le monde se souvient des images de
télévision locaux fontaine tous et j'ai
été de manière pas très victorieuse j'y
suis allé à hénin-beaumont être candidat
à l'élection législative
la fois d'avant pas celle ci donc il ya
une longue histoire de confrontation
entre elle et moi et puis c'est le jeu
du gouvernement du parti socialiste qui
sont un peu complice dans cette affaire
le tiroir à tout ça c'est tout la même
chose
bon parti socialiste aimerait bien eu
des gages pour qu'il soit tout seul à
nouveau à faire ce qu'il veut alors bon
elle est habile et moi je veux
évidemment la réponse concept qu'on
attend d'un homme comme moi après tant
d'années de confrontation avec eux et de
distance avec madame le pen sur le plan
philosophique et idéologique elle
connaît bien ce serait ignorer agissent
comme ça en non on va faire les choses
plus simplement elle dit qu'il ya des
convergences
elle devrait dire lesquels parce que moi
ce que j'ai l'impression ce dont j'ai
l'impression c'est que les divergences
se sont creusés ça peut paraître curieux
mais il ya eu un moment où il y avait
des mots qui était commun par exemple
nous on disait on veut une sixième
république il y en a assez de la
monarchie présidentielle que dans
laquelle nous vivons et on voit quelle
absurdité
ça peut ça conduit et eux ils disaient
aussi la sixième république et il ya pas
longtemps madame le pen a dit allons
nous ont pas tout ça c'est pas notre
sujet la 6ème république
la cinquième c'est très bien donc elles
aimeraient bien elle aussi être la
monarque présidentiel mais monsieur
macron bon ça c'est pour moi c'est pas
un détail sur le plan de l'orientation
le politique
moi je suis pour que les gens qui est en
quelque sorte une constituante une
assemblée constituante assemblée
citoyenne constituante soit les gens eux
mêmes qu'ils produisent
la nouvelle règle du jeu politique dont
le pays a besoin parce que tout est
bloqué on le voit bien il ya un
discrédit énorme de toutes les
institutions de
des hommes et des femmes politiques bref
donc mon idée c'est le peuple fait d'une
assemblée constituante et en définissant
ses droits à l'organisation des pouvoirs
publics comment ça fonctionne
l'assemblée le gouvernement les
collectivités locales en urgence à bâle
le peuple se définit lui même parce que
si par exemple entre nous deux on se
reconnaît un droit commun ben je sais
pas moi le droit de boire quand on a
soif de manger quand on a faim bah ça va
être une règle du jeu communes si un
jour vous vous dites la côte et manger
rien à manger on n'ira pas même temps
faut partager
voilà donc c'est pour vous dire quand
elle est contre elle et pour la
monarchie présidentielle
elle est contre le passage à la 6ème
république donc il ya eu un changement
de position et troisième élément quand
je cite que ça parce que je pourrais la
faire la liste longue sur ce plan là
quand on a line ou un amendement à
l'assemblée nationale pour dire on
proposons qu'il y ait un référendum
on appelle ça révocatoire pardon ce que
le mot un peu bizarre à référendum pour
révoquer un élu par vous n'êtes pas
contents d'un élu à partir du moment où
il y aurait un certain nombre de gens
qui en feraient la demande
on organise un référendum pour le
révoquer ce à dire diakité vous arrêtez
votre mandat ou ne pas le révoquer
bien sûr c'est ça le référendum
d'invocateur alors quand on a proposé ça
s'applique à tout le monde
le président de la république et
conseiller municipal à tout le monde
pour être soumis à référendum
révocatoire et bien à l'assemblée
nationale ils ont voté contre
alors si vous voulez j'ai pris cet
exemple je pourrais prendre celui du
smic récemment elle a dit ah ben non on
n'est pas pourquoi on augmente le smic
hasard si vous n'êtes pas pour augmenter
le smic c'est vous avez rien compris à
ce qui se passe dans ce pays parce que
dans ce pays les gens disent montrait
mais on peut partager
et puis enfin il ya le front du fonds va
pas non plus tourné autour du pot
non je suis universaliste je l'assumé
c'est à dire je crois que tous les êtres
humains naissent libres et égaux en
droit et comme c'est un peu compliqué je
me débrouille pour trouver la bonne
solution pour que cette égalité deux
principes devient une égalité réelle
n'arrive pas tout le temps il ya des
fois on sait pas comment s'y prendre il
yad'autres fond de gratte la tête en dix
ans
bon bah c'est un peu compliqué à faire
pas mariés mais n'empêche pas du tout
elle est sur une ligne comme on appelle
ça c'est un grand mot pardon on dit on
ici c'est à dire qu'elle croit que un
peuple se définit par sa religion sa
couleur de peau ou que sais-je encore
pour moi le peuple se définit par les
principes politiques il met en commun
pour marc le peuple français ce qui le
définit
c'est qu'il essaye de vivre dans une
société liberté égalité fraternité pour
tout le monde les hommes et femmes
quelle que soit la religion quelle que
soit la couleur de peau
c'est à dire que pour des gens comme moi
ce qui compte c'est l'humanité et après
il ya des différends je suis pas fou
jusqu'à incapable de les voir mais c'est
pas ces différences sur lesquels je vais
organiser les pouvoirs publics
donc je me dis et en plus pour aller au
fond de la faire elle elle considère que
bon il ya beaucoup de gens qui sont
comme ça qu'ils disent oh là là c'était
mieux avant bombe à 2 pts était
peut-être mieux avant je n'en sais rien
la partie où j'étais moi avant nom
ferait pas sens mieux je trouve très
intéressant qu'on soit comme on est le
peuple français aujourd'hui ce dont on a
besoin c'est un peu de rapprocher
davantage tout le monde mais franchement
c'est mon âge qui me permet de dire ça
c'est une nouvelle france les gens faut
atterrir le peuple que le pays vous avez
sous les yeux
c'est un pays complètement nouveau
d'abord parce que tout le monde vit en
ville ou dans des espaces urbanisés je
sais très bien qu'il ya des gens qui
vivent à la campagne bible sur le mode
urbain ces 85 % de la population il faut
se rendre compte que dans les années 50
c'était pas une proportion pareil on
puis comme ça on est 62 5 millions on
était 45
il ya 50 ans c'est un monde où il ya une
nouvelle france quai sous nos yeux et
elle est très mal organisé parce que si
vous prenez le point de départ de la
bataille de gilet jaune par exemple bac
qu'est ce que c'est c'est des gens qui
disaient tu t'excuses tentant de faire
là vous augmentez le prix du carburant
mais moi je peux pas diminué non de
kilomètres sur lequel je roule pour moi
c'est comme ça pour se poser la question
pourquoi c'est comme ça parce qu'elle
put poste-là parce qu'il ya plus d'écho
ici parce que la grande
phase aller là bas cette france-là été
organisée d'une manière telle que on
était obligé continuellement d'aller et
venir donc si vous voulez pour moi pour
terminer je suis sur la ligne de
l'égalité je pense que l'égalité c'est
ça le fil conducteur
elle égale dignité de tout le monde
voilà je fais pas triés par la religion
ou la couleur de peau elle si bon on va
pas se raconter d'histoire elle si il ya
des gens qui m'entendent qui eux ça pas
très bien si c'est moi quelles raisons
aussi s'est-elle donc je fais tout ce
que je peux pour les convaincre que
c'est moi qui ai mis beaucoup c'est
parole c'est une stratégie politique de
vouloir vous associez ensemble ouais je
crois de pau me mettre dans un bar à eau
pour si vous voulez c'est leur tactique
atos va mettre le dos au mur pour que je
passe plus de temps leur réponds bien
développés mais mes propres idées
quand par exemple je puis à l'instant je
vous dise elle a là rien compris parce
que quand elle dit on n'augmente pas le
smic
elle comprend pas ce qui se passe dans
le pays bon ben le temps que je réponde
à ces bêtises j'ai pas le temps
d'expliquer aux gens pourquoi quand il
ya 57 milliards de dividendes c'est à
dire de ce qui est distribué aux
actionnaires les gens qu'on les actions
de société ça que vous 7 milliards 1
une somme gigantesque qui a progressé de
12% sur un an
donc pourquoi je cite cette somme c'est
pour dire vous voyez il ya de la marge
pour partager pour faire payer chacun
ils reçoivent sa part pour qu'ils aient
de l'argent qu'ils soient mis dans
l'investissement pour créer des machines
pour qu'ils aient des emplois
donc je sais le faire moi tout ça mais
c'est le samedi veut qu'on parle qu'on
confronte ben comment s'y prendre et
bien et si vous confronter comment on
s'y prend pour changer la vie des
français et a que des français
maintenant on a un défi qu'est universel
qu'est le changement climatique va bien
falloir changer les process de
production la manière de se nourrir la
manière de se déplacer tout ça mais ça
c'est pas qu'une taxe bon il va falloir
trouver de l'argent
et oui les stars j'en perds le voilà
voilà la richesse qui a été produite par
par les braves gens c'est eux qui
produisent toute la richesse le
possesseur d'une action n'est jamais
produit un un petit mètre cube de quoi
se prépare dans un petit ce quoi que ce
soit d'autre que d'avoir mis son argent
à un endroit il dit prennent des risques
qu'ils prennent 0 risque zéro zéro zéro
zéro risque
ils sont gorgés d'eau
mention le les riches et les puissants
sont les assistés de la société c'est
pas les braves gens qui se battent pour
arriver à survivre et boucler le budget
d'ici la fin de semaine on sait ce
qu'ils ont sont gavées d'argent et en
veulent tout le temps plus ce qui est
absurde moi je leur dis comme philosophe
c'est absurde qu'est ce que les faire de
tout ça hein
alors je vais faire de cet argent vous
n'avez pas les emmener avec vous une
fois que vous y serait plus on aura que
l'on prend doucement de la hauteur sur
tous ces sujets notamment revenir sur le
mouvement d'aidé gilet jaune votre
analyse
oui j'invite aussi tous ceux qui nous
regardent à poser vos questions et
commentaires a réagi accusés ont
construit cela il me semble donc il sait
ces paroles de marine le pen que sur
lesquels voulait de réagir
il y en a d'autres il ya celle de
benjamin griveaux qui a parlé de vous si
nos confrères tels ont disons que vous
avez tout simplement quitté les rivages
de la république c'est des paroles très
fortes
sa journée malin parce que si vous
voulez une espèce de compétition entre
les les ma chronique pour savoir lequel
elle va dire la chose la plus offensante
la plus blessante j'espère que je
réponde comme sale mais un peu de ça les
met en scène bon ça fait maintenant ils
ont ils ont choisi à la rentrée de
criminaliser tout le monde alors léger
les jaunes bien sûr les premiers ils
traités comme des criminels ont montré
comme des factieux com
et puis moi alors moitié la france
insoumise
alors les chaque jour il ya une phrase
plus bizarre que la veille qui n'a pas
de rapport avec la réalité
par exemple il ya j'en entendais 1 qui
disait il veut casser du flic j'ai
jamais dit ça j'ai même expliqué
toujours le contraire pourquoi les
stratégies viande se retourner contre
eux n'ont peut-être qu'on en parle avec
le boyau qu'ils ont détaillé wars en
parler bon là qu'est qui a quitté les
rives de la république c'est ce jeune
homme va m'expliquer ce que sont les
avec de la république
je pense que ceux qui quittent les rives
de la république c'est ce qu'ils cessent
de considérer que le gouvernement n'est
jamais que le gouvernement du peuple
mais la souveraineté c'est le peuple
c'est pas le gouvernement est un homme
comme
monsieur griveaux il fait partie des
ministres qui quand moi je fais une
minute de silence savez il ya eu un
débat à l'assemblée nationale sur la
censure pour faire tomber le
gouvernement
bon je suis mon discours et au début du
discours jeudi faudrait pas oublier que
dans ce mouvement à l'époque il y avait
déjà dix morts 800 blessés
et je vous dis maintenant on va faire
une minute de silence à la mémoire de
ceux qui sont qui sont morts dans cette
histoire et toute l'assemblée cela y
compris les députés de la république en
marche que tu es là un jeu je dois le
dire mais évidemment se lève d'abord nos
amis mais la droite mais tous les
députés sauf le banc du gouvernement
grec tous assis comme ça les bras
croisés mais ce moment là il était
extraordinairement offensant
qui sont ces gens ils n'ont même plus de
respect pour pourquoi ces leurs
compatriotes c'est pas des ennemis on
n'est pas en guerre civile dans ce pays
le même si on pense qu'on veut on peut
regretter comme ça va trop loin quand ça
crie trop fort ou comme ça se cogne bien
sûr mais on n'est pas en guerre civile
on n'est pas ennemi on va pas
s'entretuer
donc il faut que tout le monde marque
comment dire il ya des moments comme ça
un peu spéciaux on marque une unité
peut-être pouvoir appeler quand le
lieutenant colonel beltrame a été
assassiné bon il l'a fait il a eu un
acte en courage extraordinaire on était
tous d'accord pour dire hommage à cet
homme
honneur à cet homme etc il ya des
moments où il faut savoir se rassembler
pas tout le temps parce que la
démocratie c'est pas le consensus il y
en a qui croient que la démocratie c'est
c'est bien quand tout le monde est
d'accord ben non ça c'est une dictature
ça la démocratie si on n'a pas le même
avis on discute on peut monter on peut
s'engueuler bon moi ça ravive écouter on
n'est pas non plus tous et mais un
moment donné mon nom on voit pas ce
qu'il faut bien décidés ou l'autre et
puis la majorité applique la décision
qu'elle a proposé ça veut pas dire que
la minorité est obligé d'être d'accord
enfin je suis obligé de vous expliquer
tout ça parce que à l'assemblée
nationale c'est sans arrêt que je vois
aller là bas
quant à eux mêmes le président ou
premier mini mais nier les élections
mais tiger mais nous on n'a pas changé
d'avis donc notre rôle c'est de donner
notre point de vue d'essayer de
convaincre
c'est ça une démocratie donc on fait ça
mais à certains moments on sait se
rassembler puis le reste du temps il
faut accepter que les points de vue sont
différents et que l'âge entente loin il
lors leur mode puisque le savent et ils
passent des feuilles s'appelle éléments
de langage est alors considéré peut-être
la même chose bouge alors rien à dire
contre ça pourquoi pas un bon alors
dedans il ya il met en cours des
articulations et printanière terrible
pour dire ça ben oui oui je mets en
place des institutions bien sûr je suis
pour sortir de la vème république et
faire une sixième république mais je
mets en cause des institutions mais pas
vu dans la rue avec un bâton ou je sais
pas quoi faire je les mets en cause dans
les élections là où je suis mort mon
boulot c'est à l'assemblée nationale ou
dans la conviction le travail de
conviction pour expliquer aux gens
pourquoi c'est mieux comme ça pour pour
la vie du pays donc oui je combats les
institutions de la vème république
quelqu'un sait depuis quand c'est un
crime et d'euros lui combattait aussi
les institutions celle de la quatrième
république
ils prennent un air terrible on dirait
qu'il vient de découvrir l'existence de
l'eau chaude et qu' ils sont là en train
de dire oh mon dieu ça peut devenir plus
lent bah oui c'est devenu brûlant parce
que vous n'avez jamais rien écouter et
vous continuez 10 juin dans la
république en marche je sais pas si vous
bien sûr vous en rendez compte l'aplomb
incroyable qui joignent oui nous avons
entendu nous allons à faire davantage
justement les gens vous dis arrêtez de
faire ça arrêtez d'être dans cette ligne
là bon donc si on veut que la
souveraineté reviennent dans l'ue peuple
il faut se tourner vers ceux qui disent
c'est ça qu'il faut faire
alors si vous êtes d'accord avec moi
vous tourner vers moi si vous n'êtes pas
d'accord avec moi vous préférez monsieur
maquereau ou je ne sais quoi et c'est
une démocratie vous choisissez vous vous
demander de quel côté est l'intérêt
général du pays et du peuple mais il
faut arrêter avec les noms d'oiseaux
parce que ça sert strictement à rien un
bon dans cette dans la situation que
nous vivons ce qui est à l'ordre du jour
c'est il faut que le pouvoir se le
mettre dans
tête c'est que les gens n'en peuvent
plus des décisions du type de celles qui
sont prises par ce système de monarchie
présidentielle et le groupe
parlementaire la république en macho
comme des robots à applaudir en cadence
à se lever à tenir aucun compte des
critiques qui peuvent leur être faites
tout au long de la vie de tous les jours
en aparté a été un très fort qu'on a pu
entendre sur certains manifestons pas
forcément une majorité mais qui prennent
parfois même un terme très critique et
très contesté de dictature vous en
pensez quoi
non c'est pas bon si je voulais être
démago et direz vous oui ou non une
dictature c'est pas comme ça c'est
terrifiant une dictature
j'ai longtemps participé a
personnellement à des luttes contre les
dictatures
donc je sais faire la différence entre
une dictature et le régime dans lequel
on est un et je propose qu'on ne se
trompe pas dans les mots parce que après
si vous crier au loup tous les jours le
jour arrive le tigre sait plus quoi dire
un bon donc
mais ce qui est sûr ce que les gens
sentent et n'ont pas tort c'est que
quelque chose est en train de changer
c'est à dire que les démocraties qui
errent s'énorgueillit c'est d'être des
démocraties des pouvoirs libre prennent
une drôle d'alluré quand vous entendez
par exemple le président de la
commission européenne monsieur juncker
qui dit il n'ya pas de démocratie
possible en dehors des traités européens
ba ou dit bara si monsieur à démocratie
elle peut aussi remettre en cause des
traités européens si on n'a pas le droit
de le faire qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire la punition qui a été
infligée aux grecs peut-être vous en
souvenez comme ils ont désobéi ils ont
été très maltraité ou bien quand vous
voyez que progressivement les gens
n'admettent plus qu'il ya un point de
vue contraires aux leurs c'est à dire
que le président de la république traite
de foule haineuse des gens qui
manifestent non il ya eu des gens qui
manifestaient il ya eu des moments
tendus il ya eu des moments durs c'est
clair mais c'est pas une foule haineuse
ce sont ses compatriotes et il est en
train de vouloir traiter tout ça par la
force il ya une sorte de dérive
autoritaire wiki ce sens et je pense que
c'est assez
c'est très mauvais de faire ça parce que
il peut se croire malin pendant quelques
jours mais sacrément
blessures qui sont inoubliables pour les
gens tous ces pauvres gens qui sont
condamnés si dur à de la prison ferme
1 ou qui sont mis dans le logar à l'oeil
le boxeur jeudi le boxeur parce que je
veux pas qu'on répète sans arrêt son nom
avec tous les problèmes que ça peut
poser à la famille de 2,7 en bon bien
sûr qu'il aurait pas dû donner des coups
de poing comme ça bien sûr alors il
s'est expliqué après il dit voilà
pourquoi ça s'est passé comme ça j'ai
craqué on m'a vexé ci et ça avant j'ai
été gazés jeu bon il s'explique il le
fait dans une vidéo on voit qu'ils
regrettent qu'elle est la personne qui
seraient contents de se retrouver dans
une situation pareille alors ils vivent
à lui-même à la police
oui c'est moi on le met en détention
provisoire pour quoi qui peut casser le
fait qu'ils sont mis en détention a
acheté les droits
je suis dans la nation lorsque la
justice elle est rendue au nom du peuple
français elle dans que les juges
appliquent la loi un projet jamais
l'oublier c'est pas eux qui décident
tout seul les juges appliquent la loi
donc si vous n'êtes pas contents des
juste commencé d'abord par changer la
loi parce qu'ils prennent les décisions
il peut-être qu'il faudrait que la loi
soit plus précise mais telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
on met quelqu'un en détention provisoire
quand ils représentent un risque pour la
suite c'est à dire qu'il pourrait
recommencer ou je sais pas quoi il
pourrait se sauver et s'enfuir
bon alors là on met en détention
provisoire il faut qu'ils aient raison
de mettre en jeu c'est l'une de ces
raisons là qui a été évoqué sur le fait
que comme il n'y a pas été interpellé
immédiatement que c'est lui qui s'est
rendu au bout de 48 heures ça va pas il
faut comprendre que cet homme il est
pris live il regrette son geste il
il a fait quelque chose qui lui
paraissait digne il ya une femme
d'ailleurs qui dit qui témoigne qui dit
moi il mais il m'a tiré d'affaires j'ai
dieu j'étais très mal placé et maïmat et
des bons il y faut être capable quand on
entend les subventions doxa de
paroxysmes ne pas tout régler à coups de
trique dont il faut entendre la parole
des gens alors il ya des gens qui
avaient décidé de faire une cagnotte
pour aider la famille alors on y chasse
est interdite
ça va quoi la cagnotte bas pardon vous
l'avez soutenu cette cagnotte
ouais je peux le temps de verser qu'elle
était déjà interdite mais mélissa a été
versé quelque chose eh beh je leur ai
pas fait publiquement parce que je veux
pas non plus donner l'impression j'ai
pas envie de passer des heures à me
justifier de mes amis je manque qu'on
réfléchisse pourquoi il y avait une
cagnotte pour aider la famille mais ça
c'est en principe quand même facile à
comprendre
une punition alors on épand cet homme là
il va être puni pentes raides puni lui
partout de sa famille or ces pauvres
gens ont besoin de lui de son salaire de
sa paye qui va payer les avocats
pourquoi on le met eux dans cette
situation nous la cagnotte c'était fait
pour ça pour aider la famille il n'est
pas condamné parce qu'on dit qu'on n'a
pas l'aura de ramasser de l'argent pour
payer des amendes pour une fois que ça
c'est déjà passé dans le passé des
cagnottes de cette nature mais là il est
pas condamné ce monsieur donc en fait
quand même c'est une cagnotte qui qui
était mise en oeuvre pour payer les
frais d'avocats de quelqu'un qui n'est
pas qui est présumé innocent et monte
donc c'est tout à fait légitime de faire
ça s'ils peuvent pas aller malheureux
payer les frais d'avocat donc cueilli et
de la solidarité et les gens quand y
mettre des sous dans une affaire comme
celle là qu'est ce que signifient leur
geste c'est bah oui on est d'accord pour
tout casser c'est pas vrai c'est pas
vrai ils font ça par ils se disent bon
ben ce bien pensé bien faire
il était avec nous alors bon ben on
était tous là évidemment tout n'a pas
été ce match mais on est solidaire c'est
à dire que on veut l'aider
on comprend ce qui s'est passé on a de
la compassion
on a de la solidarité et on peut pas
aller dans un peuple et me dire écoutez
la solidarité c'est pas bien la
compassion c'est une mauvaise idée
ça me rappelle cet homme qui faisait
passer des des réfugiées dans la
montagne
bon ben c'est un acte de compassion
humaine
il ya un moment où si vous voulez il ya
une loi qui est plus forte que toutes
les lois ça sert principe que tout le
monde comprend les droits de l'homme se
tue toutes les constitutions un hasard
non négociable il ya un principe qui est
peut être au dessus même des droits de
l'homme
c'est le principe de compassion d'amour
des autres de fraternité vous savez pas
pourquoi c'est comme ça je vais vous
donner un exemple tout bête de
la vie de tous les jours n'importe où
n'importe quand un gosse trébuche et
tombe
il n'y a pas un être humain qui se
précipitent pas pour le ramasser avant
même d'avoir réfléchi c'est pas vrai
quand on sait qu'un adulte qui tomba
mais quand c'est un gamin c'est
universel
un bon sac rookie en nous une part de
même qu'ils aient poussé à l'entr'aide à
travailler ensemble à se protéger les
uns les autres et c'est en ressorts
humains extrêmement profond il vient des
usages très profond à l'humanité aurait
pas survécu si elle n'est pas ça qui
était restée dans le programme
elle n'aurait pas survécu elle a survécu
parce que les éléments qui est cédée le
plus les uns les autres sur du verre et
se reproduisait bon pardon d'aller
chercher si vous aimez exemple mais moi
j'y crois à ça si on croit plus que
l'humanité est porteuse par elle même
d'un certain nombre de vertus de valeur
spontané que oui les sentiments ça a un
sens même en politique même dans la rue
et bien alors on ne croit plus à rien on
met un monde froid de quoi le monde dont
avec monsieur macron où tout le monde a
envie d'être milliardaire c'est à dire
d'exploiter les autres le la france
comme la reine monsieur macron une start
up on a trois quatre corps une bonne
idée qui se font plein de sous et puis
tous les autres qui dorment dans la rue
non donc il faut croire à ces valeurs là
ils vont vous parler de 7,7 en traits de
cette solidarité qui a vu notamment
vis-à-vis du boxeur de l'autre côté il y
en a certains qui ont mis en place une
cagnotte de soutien aux forces de
l'ordre blessés durant ces
manifestations
est-ce que vous emportez le même avis
quelle analyse en mai si stupide vous
c'est stupide c'est bien sûr parce que
les forces de
de l'ordre comme on dit pourquoi on ne
pourrait pas dire les gardiens de la
paix ça serait quand même mieux les
pharaons par une armée un os
ya pas deux camps dans la société
d'abord commençons par rappeler cette
question de principe
j'ai entendu une fois monsieur wauquiez
dire il faut condamner les violences de
chaque côté ambiance comprend pas il n'y
a pas deux côtés dans ce pays c'est pas
la guerre civile
il ya un seul côté le peuple et sa
démocratie et là il ya une crise de la
démocratie parce que les gens veulent
une chose et le pouvoir enlever une
autre
normalement dans une démocratie bon
alors au début c'est normal ceux qui ont
le pouvoir 10 buts en a été élu pour ça
donc on appris que notre programme puis
apparemment ça saoule avait une telle
difficulté que tout est bloqué barrages
on vote
qu'est ce que vous voulez faire d'autre
il faut que quelqu'un on ne peut pas
faire céder les gilet jaune et on ne
peut pas faire céder le gouvernement
par conséquent il n'y a qu'une chose à
faire c'est voter bon je donne mon avis
sur le sujet à c'est tentant mais je
reviens vous devez votre affaire de
cagnotte la police ce n'est pas encore
autonome c'est pas une milice c'est pas
des gens qui sont au service d'un parti
sont au service de la patrie de la
république bon ils ont des poids ils
obéissent aux ordres
faut pas croire que c'est de leur propre
chef que le samedi 2 1 samedi j'ai 100
dans la rue ou une place une bouclier
monribot flashball ils y vont parce
qu'on les a convoqués parce que c'est
leur travail et leur travail leur devoir
c'est de servir et d'obéir
par conséquent c'est pas à eux
personnellement qu'il faut qu'on s'en
prenne il faut qu'on discute les
conditions dans lesquelles ils sont
utilisés ils ont ras-le-bol et moi je
leur donne raison d'en avoir ras-le-bol
donc eux ils sont encore constitué ce
sont des fonctionnaires de l'état y a
pas besoin de ce genre de cagnotte
c'est à l'état prend en charge ses
serviteurs ses fonctionnaires qu'est ce
que c'est que cette histoire on va faire
la manche aussi maintenant pour pour
payer les fonctionnaires ce n'est pas
c'est une très mauvaise idée et c'est
surtout une idée qui crée une bizarre
définition non la police n'est pas la
propriété d'un camp ou d'un autre
la police est la propriété de la
république donc il faut complètement
révisé son mode de fonctionnement
il faut réviser la façon dont elle est
utilisée et il faut quelle qu'elle soit
vécue différemment par la population
donc le pouvoir arrête de présenter les
policiers comme une espèce d'armées
privées
de la république en marche parce que ça
n'est pas vrai je n'ai pas leur fonction
voilà ce qu'il faut dire alors on aura
l'occasion de revenir justement sur le
pacifique la violence dans les
manifestations au cours de ce live mais
je voulais aussi vous poser cette
question prendre un peu de hauteur
justement sur ce mouvement d'aidé gilet
jaune qui a commencé depuis près de deux
mois maintenant sur le terrain le 17e
membre mais même un peu avant sur les
réseaux sociaux
finalement avec un peu de recul pour
vous jean luc mélenchon qu'est ce que ça
dit notre société obama
je veux pas faire le malin après qu'on
ait entendu des kilos de textes de
parole déversé sur tous les plateaux bon
pour ma part j'ai évidemment le regard
d'un homme qui a connu un très long
engagement politique dans la vie j'ai
commencé à militer j'avais 16 ans
donc j'en ai vu des choses le mouvement
des gilet jaune est absolument unique en
son genre il ne correspond à aucune
catégorie politique particulière
d'ailleurs quand vous vous avez beaucoup
circulé vous avez beaucoup étaient sur
le terrain vous avez vu il ya tout le
monde est là mais met tout le monde à
l'intelligence de par mettre en avant
son étiquette son sigle et les gens par
2 qu'est-ce qu'on fait ensemble pourquoi
on est là ensemble qu'est ce qu'on veut
faire comment on va le faire
ça va depuis qu'est ce qu'ils préparent
à manger sur les ronds-points jusqu'à
est-ce que samedi on reste ici
où est ce qu'on va à paris où est ce
qu'on va au chef-lieu de du département
il ya une espèce de 2,2 de solidarité
qui c'est qui s'est construite qui nappe
qui met de côté les engagements
partisans qui sont respectables
je m'empresse de le dire c'est normal
chacun est son idée et puis peut-être
qu'elles vont changer en condos ton
disputant à force les uns avec les
autres
donc ça correspond pas une classe comme
ça c'est pas juste une classe sociale
parce que là vous avez des chômeurs des
retraités des jeunes sont en formation
des ouvriers des ingénieurs parce qu'il
faudrait pas croire
je sais qu'il ya une image qui a été
montré on croirai quand on écoute
certaines émissions à la télé alors
mieux c'est pouget les gens tuent parce
qu'ils auront fait moi je ne peux pas
blairer
alors au début c'était désir
responsables écologiques après c'était
des hyper violent après c'était tout
schiste des antisémites des homophobes
enfin j'ai rarement vu un moment de
politique ou autant de belles personnes
vous aussi grossièrement insulté le
peuple français et le faire avec une
espèce de bonne conscience de
tranquillité sont la reille se disent
oui
le soir j'ai entendu à la télévision je
vais pas dire laquelle ils avaient leurs
personnages importants de la télévision
française qui disait ah bah ils sont sur
les ronds-points alors il cache la
croûte ensemble ils boivent en cours on
n'est pas près de les déloger de l'armée
puisque ça veut dire vous prêts que les
gens prennent plaisir à être dans la
lutte bien sûr qu'il ya des moments
forts dans la lutte de chaleur humaine
de fraternité humaine mais ça c'est
toujours les grands bourgeois ont
toujours cette idée il pense que les
gens bouffons des manifs pour se
promener son gré par plaisir alors
qu'ils s'y perdent leur journée de
travail c'était donc le mouvement et
correspond à aucune catégorie sociale
particulière aucun camp politique
particulière quand dieu aucune catégorie
sociale particulière tout nous comprend
assez clair que c'est pas les patrons du
cac 40 qui sont sur les ronds points
d'ailleurs cela vous avez remarqué ils
ont jamais besoin de manifester pour
obtenir ce qu'ils veulent vous en êtes
pas rendu compte par exemple obtenu la
suppression de l'impôt sur les grandes
fortunes ballade soul i morte par les
absences scandale énorme serre vous avez
le pouvoir qu'a décidé de donner comme
sa main à main un chèque d'un million
d'euros à 100 personnes
cent personnes il avait demandé s'est
pas fait de manière à bloquer le
rond-point même pas elle-même pas fait
une paye et une page dans un journal
forcément il possède tout le journal
vous plaît ou pas besoin mais j'aurais
pu payer une pub pour dire on veut
récupérer notre idée c'est très rare ils
n'ont rien dit qu'ils ont obtenus et le
pouvoir a dit quand on leur dit vous ne
trouvez pas ça énorme quand même
oui bah non mais bon le réinvestir
l'année est terminée
cet argent il est parvenu dans la
production il ya un ministre à qui
j'avais dit m'écouter mais est ce que
vous connaissez l'économie de notre
époque c'est pas possible comment vous
pouvez croire que cet argent va
retourner dans la production
il va tourner dans la spéculation tout
le monde peut comprendre que quand vous
avez beaucoup d'argent même si vous en
avez très peu ça rapporte plus à l'est
le mettre dans la sphère financière vous
pouvez obtenir jusqu'à 10% que le mettre
dans la production ne devez vous
contenter de 4%
moi je sais bien que la plupart des gens
qui m'écoutent sépare problèmes dans la
vie
leur problème c'est d'arriver à tenir
aux gars du 10 du mois
mais pour ceux qui ont beaucoup d'argent
bon donc vous laisser dire on met ça
dans la sphère financière
d'accord ça va d'ailleurs mal tourner
bientôt dans la sphère financière
mais ils l'ont mis là dedans ne m'ont
pas mis dans la production alors le
ministre le maire à qui je faisais
larmes à cela me dit mais monsieur
mélenchon vous me demandez pourquoi je
crois ça mais parce que c'est le bon
sens je dis monsieur voudrait que c'est
le bon sens qui mène le capitalisme
aujourd'hui dans le monde
mais si c'était le bon sens ils
arrêteraient de détruire la planète or
ils sont incapables d'arrêter les
processus qu'ils ont mis en route même
si eux mêmes leurs gosses doivent être
protégés contre eux mêmes de leur
manière de faire vivre la planète de
faire vivre les êtres humains donc plus
le mouvement
j'ai les jo c'est essentiellement des
gens qui disent bande bon sens vous
demande pas d'être milliardaire dont
vous demande de partager ce qu'il faut
pour que l'on puisse vivre dignement au
de notre travail dont n'ont pas mieux
que d'aller travailler ou d'aller se
former
et puis quand tu arrives la retraite un
bon on arrête de bosser
non mais j'ai oublié de rappeler sa à
intervalles réguliers c'est qu'on
croyait que les gens sont des feignants
quand ils arrêtent de travailler mais
c'est pas un but dans la vie de travail
et le travail permet d'avoir un revenu
il permet souvent de s'accomplir soi
même parce qu'on sait faire des choses
que les autres savent pas faire et on
est content de rendre service d'une
certaine manière quand on produit
quelque chose est sûre vous êtes
contente sur votre boulot de journaliste
bomba
moi j'en connais peu qu'ils disent mon
travail ça vaut rien c'est une honte je
pas pourquoi il existe non les gens
s'investissent dans ce qu'ils font
donc c'est tout ce que demandent les
gens le droit de pouvoir vivre dignement
et disons de vivre tranquillement de
prendre les petites part de bonheur que
l'existant seul peut nous donner moi
j'appuie ce mouvement parce que je le
trouve extraordinaire de solidarité de
fraternité
je le trouve modéré dans ses demandes
contrairement à l'image qu'on peut
donner des gels et je ne vois pas ce
qu'il y'a d'exagérer dans ce qu'ils
disent et dans ce qu'ils demandent
d'ailleurs la preuve que c'est plein de
bon sens la preuve c'est qu'ils ont fini
par avoir raison et au début on est
traité de tous les noms de rues pour
finir la surtaxe a été abrogée donc
qu'ils avaient raison pourquoi at il
fallu attendre tant de temps pour se
rendre compte qu'ils avaient raison eux
ils ont pas demandé ça comme un
privilège ils ont demandé comme un fait
de justice et non les parlementaires
absolue a dit cent fois au niveau c'est
absurde
vous allez prendre 3 milliards à des
gens qui diront la langue le parterre de
l'attirer et tout ça pour quoi
pour payer 3 milliards que vous fait
cadeau aux autres parce que c'est ça la
vérité c'est tellement vrai que c'était
dans une lettre que le gouvernement
envoyée à la commission européenne en
dix ans pas de problème
d'accord on a fait un gros cadeau mais
on se rattrape sur les taxes sur le
carburant
ils ont écrit bon alors ce mouvement
voilà c'est ça qu'il représente depuis
représente une chance pour la france
parce que puisque les gens sont mis en
mouvement elle peut à transformer plein
de choses regardez cette affaire de
référendum d'initiative citoyenne parce
qu'on aurait dû revenir un petit peu
plus tard mais la foire cette question
qui est peut-être un important taux si
on l'a opéré une question tellement
plein il fait noir bien sûr dans la
région après de revenir le point par
point sur certains détails et passer la
nuit
mais il ya cette question qui se pose
également on a recueilli énormément de
témoignages sur brut sur le terrain on a
donné la parole à des zizou qui ont
expliqué pourquoi il était là et
certains disaient c'est une parole qu'on
a pas eu pendant des années on a été
oublié à la fois des médias donc des
fois il se dirigeait contre nous jouons
à eskom qu'on leur donnait pas la parole
et congélo
mais d'un autre côté il se dirigeait
aussi vers les politiques en dix ans
elle a aussi longtemps qu'ils ont
totalement oublié qu'est ce que vous
répondez à cela je réponds tout d'abord
c'est pas moi qui pose la question c'est
vous qui me la poser mais je vais vous
dire un que les médias et méprisé le
peuple c'est une certitude qui veut
qu'on peut calculer il ya déjà des
organismes qui font ça je vais pas aller
bien loin
je veux pas dire par les politiques mais
simplement la représentation qui on voit
à la télé qui ont voix eh ben on voit 2
% d'ouvriers
or les ouvriers les employés ses 23 % de
la population active et 60% des rôles
des films des tout ce qu'on voit à la
télévision ce sont des cadres et des
gammes supérieures
comment j'espère donc toute une partie
de la population qui existent pas
ensuite la couleur de peau des gens
c'est pas moi qui ai dit ça c'est le
c'est un rapport je pressais du csa
comment ça se fait que à la télévision
il ya des tas de gens qui n'apparaît
jamais le peuple français est très
divers
voilà c'est ça c'est à dire il faudrait
le csa fait des remarques
moi j'ai beaucoup de contes argué que le
csa mais j'ai aussi des moments où je
peux vous dire ce qu'ils ont dit là ce
qu'ils ont fait là c'est bien vrai qu'il
soit plus n'en sait peut-être que la
mentalité de ceux qui décident change
vous comprenez ça on est des êtres
humains je ne peux pas tout va pas se
régler à coups de règlements bien sûr
qu'il faudrait livre des règlements par
exemple pour ce qui a était de féminiser
la présence à la télévision on peut dire
qu'on a progressé s'est encore pas là
c'est encore pas la gloire ni danse qui
se doit ni dans les rôles principaux
ni dans les postes de commandement et
insipide mais bon alors qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait faire
déjà que tout le système médiatique soit
pas au service d'une vision du monde
parce que vous le service génétique mais
à bord il n'y est pas objectif pour vous
c'est ce que voulez vous savez personne
n'y arriverai jamais sa maman c'est un
sujet qui était toujours qui est
incroyable
quand je sois obligé de revenir là
dessus c'est comme le débat qu'elle
semblait en effet que nous ils peuvent
pas dire ça en français et chose
nouvelle on fait une loi contre les
fausses nouvelles
alors on a dit ben écoutez bon d'accord
c'est quoi une vraie nouvelle à e
je ne sais pas et puis à la fin bon ça a
tourné au ridicule parce que c'était une
loi qui prétend d'établir par la loi ce
qu'est la vérité mais sans y arriverons
jamais on sera calé la vérité parce que
son horizon recul sans cesse pas y'a pas
vous êtes un as maître en philosophie
pour comprendre ça la vérité nous la
cherchons nous autres les êtres humains
alors nous sommes souvent au service
d'une manière de voir le monde
les médias sont au service d'une manière
de voir le monde et quand ce monde
auquel croit est en danger eh bien ils
le défendent
et ils ne se rendent pas compte qu'ils
affrontent une marche croissante de gens
qui ne croient plus à ce monde
par exemple la publicité qui poussent
sans arrêt d'expression pour vous il
défendre qu'elle veut de l'argent celui
de leurs propriétaires quelque 90% des
médias sont possédés par le milliardaire
bon alors money faut que la presse soit
indépendante non pas sujet c'est pas
l'indépendance de la presse qui est le
sujet le sujet c'est le pluralisme
c'est à dire le fait qu'il dise des
choses différentes et on peut pas
admettre que au fond il ya cette espèce
de énorme machine qui répète les mêmes
choses d'une chaîne à l'autre sous un
angle un peu différent avec des talents
différents
nous en sommes d'accord c'est des
visages différents mais qui dit et
produit la même chose du matin au soir
et puis surtout devant un style de monde
jugent allait aborder le sujet de la
publicité a lui même parce que c'est ce
qui doit faire réfléchir aux saveurs en
système économique
un système politique c'est pas que des
règlements et des lois il vous vend une
culture avec vous êtes forcément en
quelque sorte la somme des modes
d'emploi des objets que vous utilisez
d'accord cela fois vous fait rêver quand
vous regardez une pub alors fait rêver à
des choses qui est son support de porter
un
il faut tous qu'on soit par exemple beau
musclé je sais pas quoi telle couleur de
cheveux dans le vent
ça vous vend sans arrêt un idéal pour
lequel pour accéder à cette idée à il
faut acheter acheter produire et vendre
acheter acheter acheter
c'est un monde dans lequel on vous dira
jamais fait un sourire c'est sympa bon
j'exagère je caricature mais j'essaye de
faire comprendre que le système
médiatique est la deuxième peau du
système économique et politique alors du
système économique par les valeurs qu'il
défend pas la mise en scène qu'il fait
et du système politique parce que vous
n'avez qu'à regarder les plateaux de
télé tout le monde raconte la même chose
bon hier et avant-hier c'était moi
l'horrible affreux montré du doigt pour
parrain cette bande des six il
réellement ce qu'on me reprochait
j'avais vraiment dit par exemple ce
ministricule qui le dit mélenchon il
faut casser du flic il aurait pu
vérifier les gens de joindre est ce que
c'est vrai il a dix un produit contraire
mélenchon sûr sur cette affaire là et
combien d'autres
donc ça tout le monde le voit est-ce
qu'il faut que vous compreniez vous
autres les journalistes mais je le dis à
vous parce que je sais que je vais
pouvoir finir ma phrase d'habitude je ne
peux même pas finir ma phrase il faut
vous compreniez que la détestation dont
vous faites l'objet est la rue d'origine
elle a une racine
alors évidemment et regarder comment
comment en quelques sortes le système
médiatique reproduit toutes les
inégalités de la société les malheureux
qui sont sur le terrain
dire ce qu'ils font les enquêtes qui
croient à leur métier et crois que c'est
il pense que c'est ça bon c'est allé
comme on dit c'est les médias des gens
ce nom puisque l'on veut dire médias ça
veut dire plusieurs médiums dits
intermédiaires les gens qui choisissent
d'être journaliste est un métier que
j'ai pas pratiqué longtemps que j'ai
pratiqué quand même deux ans quand on
fait ça on est content parce qu'on passe
d'un sujet à l'autre et
intellectuellement c'est super excitant
on rencontre des tas de situations qu'on
n'aura jamais connu sans ça on approche
des gens qu on approcherait passant ça
et puis on a l'impression que du coup on
donne à voir et nous fait exister on
permet à une réalité d'exister d'être vu
c'est ça que se figure chaque jeune qui
veut être journaliste et puis se
retrouve à faire des directs qui dure
deux ou trois secondes et où la question
contient la réponse est ce que tout
brûle en effet sa bru libre et donc ils
se font détester les malheureux ils font
leur boulot et puis après on passe le
plateau
plateau il y avait 50 personnes dans la
manifestation donc 2 pour y en a 1000
donc les 1000 qui sont là sont fous de
rage
et qui est-ce qui dégustent le
malheureux qui est là sur le terrain où
la malheureuse qui faisait son boulot
kiki les responsables du clan cas de ce
qui vient d'être dit sur le plateau
donc vous voyez dans ces circonstances
les chefs le savent tout ça les grands
dirigeants de des chaînes de télé ils le
savent ils savent qu'ils explosent leur
personnel en laissant comme ça à
longueur de journée répéter des propos
aussi hostiles au peuple aussi mensonger
par rapport à la réalité le sable
pourtant il continue alors ça craque en
ce moment de même que vous avez des
policiers qui veulent plus qu'ils
écoutent et où on va comme ça alors tous
les hadjis maintenant c'est un passage
généralisé
ils sont pas d'accord les policiers là
vous commencez à voir des journalistes
qui disent mais nous qu'est-ce qu'on
peut être qu'on fait là alors tous les
samedis on s'en va a expliqué que le
mouvement s'essouffle et que il ya des
violences partout alors c'est pas vrai
et puis de l'autre côté il ya aussi des
joints et ce qu'ils peuvent dire que
c'est les politiques et certains vous
cite notamment dit dont vous avez par
certains de vos propos
mille tensions supplémentaires entre des
gens dans la rue et la presse qu'est ce
que voulait alors une fois qu'ils le
sang expliquent qu'il faut qu'il le
démontre il faut qu'il le prouve il
suffit pas d'accusé moi je jeu là je
viens de faire une démonstration pour
expliquer et qui était pas une
démonstration personnel je n'ai pas mis
en cause des personnes chez mis en cause
un système
une manière de fonctionner qui fait que
le système médiatique est celui de la
paix après qu'est ce que vous voulez il
ya un côté un goût pour le spectaculaire
pour le violent pour le buzz qui fait
que vous avez tout un tas de
professionnels de la presse qui ne font
plus que ça du buzz à leurs bombes
un jour on m'accuse d'avoir dit ceci ou
cela c'est même pas vrai mais tant pis
on en parle pendant des heures à vous en
particulier par exemple il ya une phrase
une fois au moment
je vais l'aborder parce qu'elle est
venue souvent en exemple pendant la
grève des cheminots pareil le système
médiatique était horrible c'est les
cheminots privilégié glandeurs qui
faisait pas leur travail comment il
était encore là la sncf est endetté
comme c'était de leur faute à eux un bon
c'était sale ambiance et il y avait une
rage contre les journalistes terrible et
gégé trident décrit beaucoup donc je
fais des rondes note de blog
imaginez-vous je prends des risques
parce que si vous écrivez 4 bobin vous
surveillez les quatre mots mais si vous
écrivez comme c'est mon cas à 30 mai
signe par semaine bon je prends des
risques
enfin faut pouvoir parler comme un sinon
qu'il faut rester là à dire bon comme je
fais des fautes d'orthographe je n'écris
pas ou comme l'outil peut pas comprendre
plus de 140 signes
je dis rien je n'ai plus rien la pensée
c'est un processus complexe
vous voyez lâcheté des phrases longues
vous permettez de de parler donc je me
sens plus à l'aise pour exprimer je me
dis je vais peut-être aller bien arrivé
à me faire comprendre alors j'avais fait
une phrase comme ça au milieu en disant
si le la haine et le dégoût que ce genre
de méthode inspire et compréhensible ah
d'accord
et la phrase continue elle dit il me
faut traiter cette question d'une
manière rationnelle
c'est à dire avec la raison manière
raisonnable un raisons raisonnables
rationnelle pour ça fait je le dis pour
monsieur griveaux qui comprend pas tous
les maux tout ça voilà ça forme un tout
bon et alors qu'on fait toute une série
de vos confrères
c'était trop beau il allait en bout de
phrase de mélenchon qui montrent que ça
violent et où ils ont pris le début de
la phrase mais comme ils sont par me
dire ça mais pas très malin il croit que
tout le monde déteste parce que je
déteste j'veux les comprendre pour vous
les médias vous déteste selon les médias
c'est ne rien dire certes la presse vous
déteste non la presse venir ils me
détestent
si elle ne me détestent pas elle l'a
précédée à vendre donc elle fait ce
qu'elle a à faire vendre du temps de
cerveau utile comme disait le patron de
tf1 dont font leur boulot ils n'ont ni
détestation ni amitié ça ne sent pas le
problème il ya des personnes oui qui
sont absolument obsédé de moi qu'ils
peuvent
moi-même 50 60 70 tweet alors qu'ils
sont journalistes contre moi bon
normalement ce n'est pas leur métier de
chercheur ils sont pas payés pour ça
voilà ah bon ils sont aussi payés pour
faire ça bon au lieu de s'en tenir de
même pas parler de cette phrase qui a un
intérêt assez médiocre qu'il faut bien
le dire un
ils ont en liquide ont fait cueillir le
début de la phrase comme si moi je
disais oh lui et c'est bien de les haïr
et de l'aider j'ai trouvé des débutants
mais ce n'est pas mon propos que les
gens les haïssent et les trouve
dégoûtant c'est c'est leur point de vue
je suis au courant
ce que je dis c'est une part de ce bien
sûr nous devons traiter cette question
d'une manière rationnelle
c'est à dire ne pas en faire une affaire
de violence et personnel oui bien sûr je
comprends que l'on finisse par être
excédés mais je suis moi-même un témoin
c'est que vous haïssez les médias c'est
ce que vous voyez là où c'est dans les
gènes de mars sylvain d'anjou c'est
intéressant parce que tout le monde
l'écouté vous vois faire bien sûr
regardez est ce que je viens de dire
il est normal de haïr non je viens de
dire les gens de reais bon mais vous
voulez me faire me rejeter moi ça fasse
baisser face gauche et non pas du tout
mais moi c'est ce qui m'intéresse en
tant que journée c'est d'avoir le fond
de votre pensée sinon ça le jour
d'avancé je viens de vous le donner à la
première partie où vous m'avez avec
beaucoup de d'élégance et c'est parler
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
c'était la deuxième peau des systèmes je
vous ai démontré comment ça fonctionnait
donc quand vous vous êtes de l'autre
côté de la peau c'est à dire à l'endroit
où on prend les coups les coûts sociaux
la violence de la dureté de la vie
ben c'est normal que vous n'allez pas
embrassé la main qui vous frappe
si vous êtes cheminots je n'ai pas
regardé la télé en faisant on remercie
d'avoir dit le choix entre un bon à rien
en feignant trop payés non vous
ressentez vous dites mais mais c'est
dégueulasse pourquoi c'est eux qui parle
comme ça il ne peut jamais rien dire et
on peut pas répondre
et quand vous commencez à répondre vous
coupe la parole à bout de deux secondes
c'est normal qu'ils aient une réaction
comme ça nous faut comprendre que les
gens ont de la fierté
ils ont de l'orgueil et puis on vit dans
une civilisation où l'apparence compte
beaucoup donc de quel droit à cette
personne m'insulte du matin au soir à la
télévision
et moi je peux rien dire donc vous
comprenez c'est ça qui crée de la
r et à certains moments des bouffées de
haine c'est ça qui crée cette situation
mais ça veut dire moi je la souhaite moi
c'est parce que chouette dans mon
programme politique et dans ce continent
mais dans mon programme politique
j'explique pour devrait faire avec les
médias comment les médias publics
devraient être replacée sous le contrôle
d'un de ceux qui payent la taxe qui par
exemple pour élire ça peut être
l'assemblée nationale sur une liste
d'aptitude qui élirait le les chefs de
la télé publique ou le grand chef paul
une fois le président de la république
aux consultants csa on pourrait faire
comme ça ensuite il ya une forme d 2
comment dire d'égalité sociale dans les
médias qu'il faut défendre si entre le
grand chef ou le journaliste qu'on voit
sur le plateau qui est payé
trente mille euros par mois comme c'est
le cas dans plusieurs grandes chaînes
ayant pas forcément tout le monde et pas
forcément bien c'est exactement cela
c'est exactement ce que je veux vous
dire ce n'est pas normal que les en
étant avec des privilèges fiscaux qui
viennent juste d'être mis en cause parce
que ils sont très peu nombreux par
rapport à ceux tard par papa pas très
peu nombreux mais ils sont là et c'est
eux qui commandent mais c'est comme dans
les entreprises
ils sont très peu nombreux à toucher
beaucoup mais c'est eux qui commandent
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
par exemple j'ai proposé que j'ai jamais
un écart plus grand que de 1 à 20 dans
les salaires dans une entreprise on peut
resserrer d'ailleurs on pourrait dire de
1 à 10 c'est bien assez
moi j'ai pris le chiffre de 1 à 20 parce
que c'était le chiffre que proposait la
confédération européenne des syndicats
je voulais pas faire l'exagérer en
rajouter mais quand depuis il ya
d'autres partis qui ont proposé d'autres
fourchette c'est à dire de 1 très bien
de mardi donc dans une rédaction
il devrait pas y avoir des cartes plus
grand que deux ans à 10 d'accord or vous
avez des gens qui sont payés au lance
pierre qui sont payés avec des statuts
tout à fait incertain et qu'on met dans
la rue rené cours et on est au micro
caméra qui dérouille toi ça c'est pas
acceptable parce que qu'est ce qui se
passe au fond raconter la vraie vie dans
le journaliste pour comprendre de quoi
on parle
celui qui est dans cette situation et
détenus comme ça il est comme tout le
monde pour qu'il paye ses traites de
voitures ou de sa maison s'il a des
gosses qui l'amène à man
d'accord il va pas prendre de risque le
garçon ou la fille qui fait ça il va pas
te avait finalement pourtant les ans
prennent souvent des risques qui tendent
le micro ils prennent des interviews de
jean kitty dans la mare habchi et ça et
puis après tout ça qui disparaître y a
plus rien qui remonte et ils ne peuvent
pas protester pourquoi parce qu'ils sont
tenus social vous qu'un pas que
socialement et à la manière de produire
l'information qu'à une grande important
si vous mettez un malheureux qu'à cinq
sujets dans la journée moi je suis
parlementaire
j'ai quatre assistants et je sens que je
sujet continuellement d'accord vous êtes
d'accord vous vous changez aussi de
sujets la preuve c'est que demande
occupent des sujets dont je m'occupe moi
vous vous en occupez vous aussi moi j'ai
quatre assistants vous en avez zéro et
vous devez donc tous les jours avoir une
pensée très clair très fine très
documenté sur alors d'abord c'est la
météo pourquoi le temps a changé
bon je blague il vient la fin de la
journée ça va être un cas social une
entreprise qui ferme au milieu vous avez
un problème de l'écologie qui s'opposent
comment voulez vous que des gens
puissent produire une information de
qualité dans des conditions pareilles
alors heureusement des journaux y arrive
mais qui ont peur des mots clés instaure
le climat de confiance pour clôturer sur
ce chapitre des médias comme on aurait
un store ce climat de confiance parce
que j'aurai vous en fait un constat très
critique vous et croyez le club
politique enfin constat le plus critique
aujourd'hui voilà comment je vois les
noirs je viens de proposer des pistes
j'en ai pour pratiquement toutes les
situations je pense que par exemple
devrait pas y avoir de rentrer dans les
détails là c'est peut-être est trop cuit
n'est par exemple plus aucune
plus aucun service d'information semble
un comité de rédaction
il est un endroit où il n'y a pas de
comité d'action c'est un type tout seul
je vois un homme ou une femme qui décide
tout seul dans son bureau ce qu'on va
faire ce qui passe qui passent pas et
ainsi de suite bon c'est des détails
mais c'est pas pour le bleu comme on dit
à la presse privée moi c'est une chose
mais pour le service public a renoncé
là c'est notre bien commun je crois que
sur tout ce qu'il faut faire l'effort
c'est de renoncer à l'idée de vaches
sacrées vous savez quand on parle du
statut des cheminots là on a le droit de
critiquer dès qu'on critique la
situation dans les médias on a
l'impression que l'on va a tenté la
liberté dans l'indien mal mais mes
critiques j'ai toujours argumenter avec
des propositions des contre-propositions
les réponses que j'ai sont incroyables
par exemple le président de reporters
sans frontières comme elle ils devraient
s'intéresser à ça il n'a pas un mot à
dire quand le président de la république
dit c'est plus des médias ces sondes et
ce sont des accusateurs que nous avons
dans l'urne le président dit ça
normalement il aurait dû dire li dont
vous êtes le premier magistrat du pays
où pouvait pas parler comme ça hein
vous n'êtes pas un passant dans la rue
vous êtes par monsieur mélenchon vous
n'êtes pas un chef de syndicats vous
pouvez pas parler comme ça nous dit rien
par contre il fait un papier oui dit que
je suis une menace pour la liberté
d'informer que je n'aime que la
propagande pendant qu'elle ne rompit
gymnase pour qui pour quoi j'ai
seulement appel hollande qu'il traitait
d'apprenti dictateur un calcul cynique
mais mes pauvres humains
mes textes et mes discours pour produire
mes idées donc la situation dans les
médias nous devons nous y intéresser
c'est pas un sujet comme ça le la
réponse de l'information en donner ces
temps de voir dans une démocratie on a
besoin des médias sinon si on ne peut
pas en occupons à sa vie honda ces
choses à faire on ne peut pas chacun
chez soi installé c'est pourquoi un
comité de rédaction
donc on attend des professionnels qui
nous amène des choses bien calibré bien
réfléchi aussi proche que possible de ce
qui se passe vraiment je dis bien aussi
proches que possible en ou non pas une
absolue perfection on a besoin des
médias dans une démocratie dans une
république il ya deux piliers au temple
premièrement l'école qui nous permet de
devenir des êtres libres
intellectuellement capable d'avoir de
l'esprit critique et deuxièmement les
médias l'information
parce que c'est ce qui nous permet quand
on lui dit ben monsieur il faut vadam
pauvreté elles ont été bien voter mais
sur quoi
quel est le sujet comment il doit
comprendre un des gens il cherche à
comprendre disait me comprendre il aime
à prendre un et bien voilà pourquoi on a
besoin d'une école de très haut niveau
avec beaucoup de professeurs beaucoup
d'instituteurs pour que tout le monde
soit bien formés et deuxièmement un
système médiatique qui soit moins crispé
et moi accaparé par l'argent que qu'il
ne l'est aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression
de lire des choses de simple bon sens
mais le simple fait de les dire nouveau
une vindicte absolument dans
l'incroyable des gens qui sont installés
dans la place et qui se figurent que je
les ai ou que je vous que j'ai un compte
à régler avec eux mais je n'ai pas de
comptes à régler
je me préoccupe des médias quand je me
préoccupe de tout le règne les aspects
de la politique du pays peut-être qu'on
va en parler alors oui justement il est
cette question on parle beaucoup des
manuels macro et à ses slogans parfois
qu'on l'entend mâcon démission sans ce
mouvement des gels et jaune mais
finalement est-ce que ce n'est pas une
succession de politique depuis des
décennies qu'on conduit à ce ras le bol
c'est ce qu'on entend régulièrement dans
certains témoignages de gila oui
aujourd'hui est ce que c'est
macron le responsable ou ses camarades
important ce qui compte c'est le moment
où on est bien sûr que c'est la longue
suite ça fait maintenant en cas de
président de la république qui
pratiquent au moins 4 1 qui pratiquent
la même politique libérale avec le même
but la même idéologie qui les aveugles
qui les rend fous qui pensent que c'est
la compétition par tous qui va régler
l'économie alors que nous nous croyons
que c'est la coopération que c'est ce
que les gens n'arrêtent pas de dire
écoutez vaudrait mieux s'entendre
travailler différemment que de faire
comme on le fait ils ont tout privatiser
en dix ans les prix vont baisser et plus
rapide ça pendant des années on nous a
dit le service public c'est inefficace
et tout est beau mon téléphone mieux
maintenant le gaz il chauffe mieux
qu'avant non bien sûr pas mais coûte
plus cher c'est tout c'est la seule
différence mais y est privé de même m
plus ils vont privatiser le train vous
savez comme moi ce que ça va donner on
va fermer des milliers de lignes qui
sont pas rentables qui autrefois étaient
gérés par le fait que globalement le
système était rentable tiens ça me fait
penser à une différence quand on a
proposé un amendement pour que l'on ne
puisse pas privatiser le train les amis
de madame le pen ont voté contre
d'autres amendements je dis ça au
passage parce que ça me revient à
l'esprit mais c'est pour vous dire toute
cette politique les gens l'ont vu
enfin et réveillons nous il ya encore
pas longtemps il y avait une pause dans
chaque village non au le pays était
tellement plus riches à l'époque n'ont
été moins riches ont été moins nombreux
à l'époque et maintenant on est plus
nombreux il ya moins de postes
jeudi poste pour prendre cet élan il ya
moins d'école il ya moins de lignes de
chemin de fer qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est ce qui va pas là dedans on
l'expliquer on voulait expliquer donc
monsieur macron il a été élu pourquoi
pas parce que les gens tout d'un coup et
ève nault teese est en partie un parent
lui sait même pas que ces discours était
performance et on dira best-of il est
jeune il a rien à voir avec tout ça il
va nous faire un peu le ménage là-dedans
on va arrêter toutes ces bêtises
non c'est pire qu'avant c'est à dire que
c'est la même chose qu'avant c'est dur
c'est brutal on change le code du
travail pour serrer encore la gorge les
gens on donne encore plus aux riches
qu'on donnait jusqu'à elle non plus
qu'ils amplifient la sphère donne plus
on passe le on supprime lisf ont fait le
machin là qui s'appelle le crédit impôt
compétitivité emploi 40 milliards qu'on
donne comme ça encore bon c'est pire
qu'avant et au plus par un gars qui vous
méprise c'est à dire qui dit ware dans
les gares il ya des gens qui ont réussi
leur vie et notre sait rien comment rien
comme il parle je suis la personne n'a
jamais parlé comme ça aux français je
suis un homme qui vient de la gauche
comme vous le savez donc j'en ai passé
des meetings et des batailles avec ceux
de droite
jamais entendu
on aura de parler comme ça avant il
parlait pas comme ça et j'étais sonné il
n'y a pas d'accord c'est clair on défend
des pas la même vision du monde vous
parlez pas comme ça aux français je me
rappelle pas d'un président de la
république et 10 offensifs êtes derrière
des gaulois réfractaires en bus allait
raconter ça à l'étranger
qu'est ce que c'est que cette façon de
faire et je vous passe tout leur est bon
plus un système mais grossier de deux
poids deux mesures vous avez en gare
notre ami le boxeur qui regrette d'avoir
boxer ce jour la dgac avait un bouclier
alors lui il va en prison préventive et
monsieur bénard lui la boxe ces deux
personnes étaient retenues par les
autres il est oui il en train de se
balader d'un pays à l'autre en avion
avec des passeports diplomatiques de la
république française bon tout le monde
le voit prenez pas les gens pour des
idiots croyez pas que les gens n'ont pas
fait attention ils ont vu ils
comprennent qu'il ya deux poids deux
mesures ils comprennent que quand
monsieur carlos ghosn qui est le patron
de 2,2 au nord ni ça il a eu une
embrouille avec le fisc japonais un tout
le monde sait ça je vais pas m'exprimer
dessus parce qu'on va dire que je
conspirent contre l'industrie automobile
nationale
je peux dire ça je lui dire la phrase
que pense monsieur le vert
le ministre de l'économie karti plutôt
froide pas prêt pas bien c'est pas un
gars qui s'énerve alors on lui dit
qu'est ce que vous pensez de sa garde en
moi j'ai rien à dire il n'y a pas de
problème avec la situation fiscale de
monsieur carlos ghosn vous êtes content
moi aussi je compte en a pas de problème
avec l'association fiscale s'il ya un
problème il paye pas ses impôts en
france et il est le patron de la plus
grosse boîte de bagnols du pays et
combien comme ça et c'est les mêmes qui
vient de vous dire après vous ne pensez
pas à l'intérêt général
au fond ces grands capitalistes et tous
ces gens ils n'ont pas la patrie tout ce
qui compte lors seule patrie c'est leur
argent
voilà alors qu'ils habitent autour de la
france a mais il viendra en france vers
leurs affaires et ramasser leurs
milliards vous voyez c'est tout ça les
gens le savent et ils comprennent que
ils ont peuvent plus de ça vous me posez
la question d'hier est ce que c'est sa
faute non s'en fout de savoir si c'est
sa faute il a aggravé les choses
au moment
j'espérais qu'il allait changer tout ça
et puis ils auraient dû être prudent un
peu un peu réfléchir à sa situation le
gars il fait 23% au premier tour il se
retrouve élu au deuxième avec plus de 60
parce que il ya l'extrême droite et que
les gens disent banger dans les deux cas
on veut pas laisser passer
l'extrême droite donc il a massivement
était élu mais au point de départ le
gars il a 10 % du corps électoral ça lui
donne pas le droit de tout fiche en
l'air d'agresser tout le monde
d'insulter les gens dans le pays
on a le droit quand on est un chef
politique dans d'un parti d'un mouvement
parle d'une certaine manière mais quand
au moins entre en situation alors ça
change tout c'est la france dont il est
responsable c'est pas juste de sa bande
à vous évoquez quelques instants les la
situation d' alexandre bédat cette
comparaison
je vais vous apprendre une information à
vous et notamment à ceux qui nous
regardent à 19h06 c'est que la
commission des lois du sénat dans son
enquête sur la sphère benalla à
convoquer à nouveau avec son bel avenir
donc à des auditions qui se dérouleront
du 16 au 21 janvier et auquel
participeront également notamment
christophe castaner le ministère de
l'intérieur
quelle réaction s'avoue suscite sûrement
venir lui racontera ce qu'il veut et
puis il y aura aucune sanction parce que
ils ont déjà menti tous ces gens devant
les deux commissions parlementaires
normalement les commissions
parlementaires c'est pas une par un
tribunal
1 mais vous déposer sous serment vous
jurés me dire la vérité et rien que la
vérité toute la vérité vous vous vous
jurer que vous allez dire la vérité vous
êtes devant la représentation nationale
ils mentent comme des arracheurs de
dents comme on disait autrefois mentir
comme un arracheur de dents mais voilà
quelle conséquence il y en a pas
toujours en liberté et grands qui sort
il bâille bien lui quand il a une
perquisition chez lui on lui téléphone
avant monsieur beczala on peut venir
demain alors je peux pas de marc voilà
ça s'est passé comme ça et ce n'est pas
demain parce que j'y suis pas été alors
il arrive le lendemain les clés j'ai
passé ma femme qu'ils m'ont a rien de
tout ça
d'accord donc tout le monde voit c'est
ce que je vous est alors qu'il ya deux
poids deux mesures
deux manières de dinde être traité dans
ce pays ce n'est pas normal
et personne n'est d'accord avec ça il
faut quand même le savoir
tout à l'heure je vous parlais des
policiers mais je crois pas qu'il juge
et les avocats soient fins contents du
nouveau régime qui est en train de se
voter la loi sur la justice qui va
repasser à l'assemblée nationale tout le
monde est vent debout parce qu'on voit
bien que du doigt à l'autre on est en
train de tout durcir tout à l'air avait
tout rendre encore plus difficile tous
les ans on vote une loi pratiquement la
moyenne c'est à peu près ça sur la
sécurité intérieure
personne n'a jamais fait le moindre
bilan de ce qu'on a fait tous les ans
vous m'entendez on doit en être à la 10e
ou là où la 15e loi sur la sécurité
intérieure
sur la fère benalla voulait revenir
dessus certains points le terme d'
affaire d'état ce que pour vous c'est
vous partager cela pour vous la fermez
le mot à fleurs d'état ça permet bon ça
fait comme ça du bruit qui à gauche mais
il faut quand même regarder le fond de
la faire oui c'est très grave
c'est gravissime alors voilà un homme je
vous passe tout le premier rang de la
sphère bennane à toulouse la res pris
mon gars qui décide d'aller jeu tabasser
des gens dans la rue au milieu des
policiers
bon avec tout ce qu'on a découvert
qu'ils avaient en plus des armes chez
lui un coffre fort qui a disparu enfin
bref une manière d'exercer la justice
absolument incroyable vous vous n'avez
pas oublié que ils ont trouvé des armes
au siège de la république en marchant on
n'a pas trouvé aussi un jeu la france a
soumis un apparent pas la peine de
chercher à pas bon il en avait ça ça n'a
pas fait l'ombre d'un bruit mois 3
parole oui des armes dans leurs locaux
non c'est pas un problème et lui
monsieur benallel avait encore que
disent pas
embêter les gens pour qu'ils il ya un
corps qui disparaît les armes qu'ils et
elles ont disparu aussi est cet homme
cet homme maintenant poser un problème
gigantesque tout ça tout le monde le
savait vous êtes d'accord tout le monde
le savait c'était grave
déjà on a passé tout l'été là dessus et
on découvre à la rentrée la passeport
diplomatique qui roule à laisser
circuler avec ça alors je vais faire
attention aux grands mots mais quand
même quelqu'un est coupable dans cette
affaire c'est curieux il n'y a pas de
responsables donc on a laissé un
passeport diplomatique à quelqu'un qui
faisait l'objet d'une d'une dune
affaires monstrueuses connu dans ce pays
et il a quand même eu un passeport
diplomatique
personne ne la recupèrerait mieux on lui
a rendu et on veut nous faire croire que
personne ne le savait edit ah oui bon je
l'écris avant donc un quelqu'un dans un
ministère à écrire monsieur benalla pour
le dire a coûté forum des passeports
diplomatiques je veux bien croire que ça
a été fait alors pourquoi personne après
s'en est soucié
donc ça veut dire que tout le long ça se
savait et tout le monde fermait sa
bouche
et puis un jour quelqu'un dit en a marre
parce que c'est ce que je vous ai tout à
l'heure le gagner dans la diplomatie et
uniquement je suis pas d'accord pour pas
d'accord pour couvrir des pratiques
pareilles c'est pas l'idée que je me
fais de mon métier c'est pas l'idée que
je me fais de la france c'est pas l'idée
que je me fais de la diplomatie
française c'est quand même le deuxième
réseau du monde
un jeu pas d'accord pour que personnage
comme ça là circulent en avion dans un
endroit alors d avion privé avec un
passeport diplomatique c'est le niveau
le plus élevé 1 de passeport pour pour
une vue d'une personne je vous garantis
qu'on vous le récupère derrière quand
j'étais ministre et fait plusieurs
voyages à l'étranger et j'avais un
passeport diplomatique comme on a donné
deux fois non mais récupéré juste
derrière on me disait pas monsieur
mélenchon zecca regarder c'est ce que
vous voulez avec arun ou londres et
comme noël temps non non on leur rendait
tout de suite le rendait c'est normal
d'ailleurs je me demande et regardez
qu'est ce que j'aurais fait qu'un avec
un passeport diplomatique
mais donc quelqu'un a craqué et a été
voir un journaliste elle le dit mais
voilà la faire rouler ce qui se passe
donc oui c'est très grave
ça veut dire qu'il ya une chaîne
ou bien personne ne contrôle rien à la
tête de l'état puis c'est grave
je ne le crois pas ou bien il ya une
espèce de d'ambiance
comment dire au bon tout ça est acceptée
supporter moi j'ai dit à un moment donné
avec mes amis que vous voyez qui avait
une structure de commandement policiers
par appel par pardon parallèle à celui
de la police nationale bon et vous avez
vu comment monsieur collomb s'est
défaussé de cette histoire c'était lui
qui était ministre de l'intérieur à la
faire à l'époque dimanche au courant de
rien j'ai pas qui est monsieur benalla
je le connais pas l'autre j'ai jamais vu
et puis là dessus a dit si un problème
n'est qu'à voir le préfet de police de
paris n'étaient pas trop content de se
retrouver à avoir tout d'un coup la
sphère benalla sur les genoux est ce que
l'on est parti et a laissé en plan tout
le monde donc maintenant la haute
fonction publique de l'état
elle sait que les politiques n'assument
pas leurs responsabilités et que quand
il ya un gros problème ça retombe sur
les genoux des hauts fonctionnaires donc
vous en avez un certain nom qui commence
à dire mais moi j'ai pas envie d'être
pris là dedans et qui commence à dire ne
vous veux plus faire 700 bloqués de se
taire quand il se passe des choses qui
ne sont pas acceptables du point de vue
de la morale dans l'idée qu'on se fait
du fonctionnement de l'état j'espère que
je me suis bien fait comprendre pour
dire c'est sale ambiance cas en ce
moment au château une petite bande est
arrivée qui elle même à dix on a pris le
pouvoir par effraction
c'est le président macron lui-même qui a
parlé de l'ohl 2 1 et qui a accaparé à
quelques dents naturellement en ayant la
confiance de personnes dans l'état ne
sachant pas comment des l'état et en
plaçant comme ça par ci par là des
personnels bizarroïde pas même trait à
de très haut niveau qui qui font les
choses à la place du fonctionnement
normal de l'état
les passeports diplomatiques sont donnés
à des gens qui ont une mission de l'état
décidée par l'état et pour lui vous avez
fait un bref parallèle par rapport à
votre situation personnelle vers
questions qui sont des rayons locaux en
fin d'année dernière
très concrètement ça en est où
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on est tous
restés sur cette situation
en mois d'octobre aujourd'hui ce que
vous avez eu des nouvelles depuis
c'est parce qu'ils n'ont même façon je
ne pensais pas que j'adorais par exemple
monsieur
ayrault qui lui faisait l'objet d'une
procédure de presque deux ans après il a
plus personne
on est sur le moment il ya un effet
spectaculaire ddt des problèmes mangez
pas vous saouler avec ça parce que c'est
j'essaye de cicatriser d'accord j'ai été
humilié comme vous pouvez l'imaginer de
deux façons la première par la manière
avec laquelle j'ai été traitée vous
savez il ya des choses auxquelles on
croit profondément dans la vie bon moi
la république ça vous faire sourire mais
c'est une religion pour moi mon écharpe
tricolore les élus du peuple croit tout
ça je je je suis pas née qu'une cuillère
d'argent dans la bouche je viens du
peuple donc pour moi c'est des mots
importants dont par exemple à hong hong
et j'ai dit à ma personne et ça crée
alors tout le monde s'écoute le marbre
je comprends qu'on se moque de moi parce
que en plus j'étais pas il était plutôt
énervé au moins je fais ça tu voues côté
parlons vous regrettez moi il s'agit une
question du journaliste
je ne mets de ma vie je ne regretterai
d'avoir défendu ma dignité s'il veut
faire vite en 2005 les bouées notre
n'intéresse personne à part vous qui qui
qui derrière cet écran dit monsieur man
show est ce que vous regrettez parce que
c'est trop parce que c'est ça qui est
sous-entendu beaucoup de critiques à
votre encontre et je m'en fous les
critiques monsieur qui me critiquaient
les mêmes plateaux de médias qui toutes
façons critiquent quoi que je dise quoi
que je fasse
et ils n'ont même pas eu leur sort
professionnel qui aurait été de dire
mais est ce que c'est normal de faire
tout ça quelqu'un aurait pu dire sur un
plateau attendait il est parlementaire
ce thème là non le mot il ya un truc
s'appelle immunité parlementaire
on a réduit sa liberté on a l'accord du
bureau de l'assemblée
non personne n'a été demandée à
l'assemblée si on avait droit de surgir
chez en parlementaire qui plus est
président d'un groupe mais je vais quand
même aller oui c'était très humiliant
mais c'est aiguilleurs parce que je n'ai
jamais cru que tout ça aurait pu avoir
lieu comment c'est possible entre
appareils une élus d'extrême droite
dénoncent 17 parlementaires pour comme
ça parce qu'elle dit elle même c'est un
pied de nez à la justice
et ça nous donne une perquisition
moi comment parce que les autres ont pas
été perquisitionné chez eux tous mes
anciens collaborateurs le malheureux des
jeunes à qui on prend tout tout ce qu'il
ya dans leur ordinateur tout ce qu'il ya
dans toute leur vie privée alors tout
tout est parti comme ça donc tout le
monde est traumatisé je vous demande de
l'entendre mais surtout et je vais je
vais le redire là devant des gens qui
d'habitude et coûte peut-être pas ce
genre de rubrique à la télévision je
vais vous dire moi pourquoi je suis allé
aussi agi de mon mouvement les gens
pourquoi j'ai fait ça cela peut rester
tranquillement chez moi attend que ça se
passe c'est que dans le sillage de mon
mouvement comme j'ai vu ce qu'on faisait
chez moi comprenez tout ce qu'il y avait
dans l'ordinateur qui vont aller là bas
et vont prendre tout ce qu'il ya dans
l'ordinateur y compris le fichier où il
ya vote nous vous êtes 500 milles qui
m'avait donné votre nom de tous les
métiers de toutes les branches de tous
les aspects du pays
d'accord et ben moi je ne voulais pas
qu'on prenne le fichier de la france
insoumise voilà pourquoi je me suis
fâché comme ça et puis après oui j'ai
commis une erreur ça c'est clair
tournée commune c'est d'avoir cru que je
serai défendue par les défenseurs
traditionnelles de la démocratie et de
la liberté c'est une chose qu'on n'avait
jamais vu une affaire comme celle là
cent policiers pour perquisitionner deux
des gens qui sont accusés sur la base de
simples dénonciations
d'accord c'était bon ben voilà mais
maintenant je vais quand même conclure
sur une chose pour prendre les devants 1
pour préparer la suite
je vais vous raconter la suite dans tous
les pays du monde des hommes comme moi
ou les femmes comme moi la manière de
les liquider
c'est de leur faire des ça s'appelle la
au phare je crois en anglais c'est des
attaques juridiques
donc on a mis par exemple l'ancien
président qui était en tête des sondages
pour la présidentielle au brésil lula
qui a un ouvrier métallurgiste qui a été
président et il était à nouveau en tête
dans les sondages pour pour être élu
éolien on l'a inculpé et mis en prison
pour 12 ans pour
avoir été a reçu un pot de vin qu'elle
planchait sur une corruption quel
corruption on me l'a dit on vous a
offert un appartement il ya dix lequel
non tu le vois jamais vu je sais pas
quoi vous parlez eh bien le gars il est
en prison et le team qui l'a mis en
prison le juge qui l'a mis en prison lui
lula en l'accusant d'avoir reçu un
appartement comme pau devant lui il est
devenu ministre de la justice du via
d'extrême droite qui s'y trouvent
aujourd'hui dans tous les pays c'est
comme ça il ya une attaque juridique le
pouvoir politique instrumentalise la
justice et grâce à ça permet de se
saisir de la personne 2 de démolir
politiquement donc monsieur bayrou paris
l'on ne sait pas c'est pas c'est pas mon
ami politique monsieur bâillon n'est pas
omis lui il m'a chronicité pour macro
pas moi monsieur bayrou c'est pas juste
qu'ils l'ont fait toc
il est il fait l'objet d'une procédure
il voit plus personne il peut plus être
mini s'il peut plus rien faire
et si jamais il ressort le nez de la
boîte ont valu dirait monsieur il ya la
faire là bas on a tous compris comment
ça fonctionne ça fonctionne comme un
moyen de pression je ne sais pas ce qui
va m'arriver
mais comme je trouve incroyable d'être
pris dans une histoire à propos a
partant d'une dénonciation et l'autre or
c'est pire que tout c'est l'histoire du
financement de la campagne du parti j'ai
dit mais plus d'un an des
présidentielles j'ai dit m'écouter or en
fait renvoyer tous les comptes je suis
d'accord vous voulez pas les autres moi
je veux bien
je veux bien qu'on réexamine tous mes
comptes d'un bout à l'autre et qu'on me
dise qu est ce qui là dedans n'est pas
normal moi j'ai passé ma vie à répondre
à des questions 2000 j'en ai reçu de
questions à la fin quand on a rendu les
cons et tout le monde demande et alors
est ce qu'on aura de persil est ce qu'on
parle l'autre car ça il avait à zéro
dans la commission à cause du passé de
la sphère de monsieur sarkozy et de la
sous facturation
tout ça peut paraître lointain si vous
voyez c'est ça qui est qui abusent de
leur part c'est ce que comprennent
beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui parce
qu'ils ont affaire à la justice en c'est
qu'on vous met dans une embrouille le
temps que vous l'expliquer tout le monde
qu'est ce que c'est encore cette
histoire on comprend pas bien il n'y a
pas de fumée sans feu
en plus on vous fait un motif en voudra
vous êtes présumé innocent mais quand
même on vous soupçonne d'être un menteur
en voyou un voleur un escroc rien qui
l'énoncé des la suspicion vous êtes des
gens malades de l'entente dire moi je
comprends d'ailleurs les gens qui jeu
que j'ai au téléphone la patiente et que
des des amis j'ai des amis quand même
parmi les jets des gens d'où qu'ils
m'appellent monsieur mélenchon secours
qu'est ce que je vais pouvoir persuader
dossier saez ou morts de peur d'eux des
inculpations qui a contrôlé on voit que
là vous avez entendu le président de la
république
il a extrêmement vérité de quoi il se
mêle c'est le juge qui décide comme on
applique une peine sait pas c'est pas
une machine automatique la justice on
n'a pas besoin de juges ont duré vous
vous avez coché la case de 40 pouces
temps de donner de prison en amande non
il ya un juge le juge il évalue et je
dis bon alors qu'il compte des
circonstances je tiens compte de ce
qu'on ça c'est pas vrai ça c'était vrai
ou le gala notre ami le jeudi notre ami
le boxeur puisque moi il m'a rahim a
remué des sens là il m'a mis les larmes
aux yeux quand j'ai vu expliquer écouter
j'aurais pas dû faire ça tout ça je sens
le gac et paniqué il doit se dire mon
dieu ma famille tout ça bon bah stop là
il est il est il et il faut évaluer la
situation c'est ça que doit faire le
juge
et c'est pour ça qu'il nous faut des
juges et pas des machines et les juges
eux ils disent mais nous on applique la
loi ils sont d'ailleurs là pour ça on ne
comprendrait pas qu'il fasse autre chose
mais il faut qu'ils signent une latitude
pour apprécier comment la loi doit
s'appliquer
nous sommes pas une société de rombeau
et de machines nous sommes une société
d'êtres humains donc dans la vie des
êtres humains tout est relatif bien sûr
la loi s'applique mais il faut
l'appliquer avec intelligence des
situations par aggraver les plaies par
augmenter les tensions dans la société
si à la fin de tout ça vous avez votre
collègue puisque vous me parliez de
journalistes comme soir alors
l'interview de monsieur edouard philippe
premier ministre vient se demande
pourquoi ouvrir des fins
celle du 20h de téléphone cet oubli oui
alors bon il dit il vient faire son truc
il vient pays qui on va faire des lois
pour rendre ça plus sévère très bien
reconnaît j'ai entendu dix fois c'était
dans tout paris on dit là il va rien
télévision où il va déclarer qu'elle
vient juste déclaré qu' il va mettre des
lois encore plus dur et là il se passe
une chose absolument incroyable le
journaliste est sur le plateau je dis
oui mais vous en avez arrêté sallaumines
a interpellé cinq mille personnes
parfait elle interpellé cinq mille
personnes et le jaune c'est le
journaliste qui disent ah oui mais vous
n'en avez condamné que 140 la question
qui devrait se poser c'est comment vous
avez fait pour ramasser 4860 personnes
pour rien qui ne relève d'aucune
procédure d'aucune sorte
ça serait une question on peut y
répondre mais pas faire ce sale boulot
qui consiste à dire allez on ramasse
tout le monde qui ont puni tout le monde
et ça n'a pas traîné ça crée une belle
ambiance que 24 heures après vous avez
l'ancien ministre luc ferry qui dit oui
bah les positions car servir de leurs
armes
et d'ailleurs on a une armée et elle est
la quatrième du monde et il faudrait
qu'elle fasse c'est à dire que l'on
finit par traiter le peuple tout entier
comme un ramassis d'ennemis mme c'est
pas bon ça c'est pas comme ça qu'on gère
un pays c'est pourquoi je je je vous le
redis la loi doit être appliquée avec
une interprétation une personnalisation
de la peine évidemment en appliquant la
loi ça va de soi cette question de
mathieu auclair converser dans les
commentaires qui parlent du son de votre
programme
or à la mise en place d'une vième
république c'est vrai qu'on en parle
beaucoup actuellement avec les réformes
que certains demandent notamment au sein
du mouvement
des gilets jaunes en quoi ça
consisterait concrètement sur les points
majeurs alors là il ya une branche
commence par expliquer ce qui est
souvent vous savez le mot passe pas
parce qu'on ne comprend pas bien ce que
ça veut dire
jeudi une constituante et moi je pars
tout le monde comprend en majidi me
acteurs qui comprend une constituante ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire
il faudrait donc convoquer une assemblée
constituante ça s'est déjà vu à dire
c'est une assemblée où les gens bien du
succès la règle du jeu
voilà discute alors on a vu dans
plusieurs pays
ce truc se faire bon mois celui que j'ai
aimé le plus de la plus belle assemblée
constituante qui m'a plu c'est celle qui
a eu lieu en équateur sous la présidence
de monsieur rafael correa
alors il il est arrivé à peu près comme
ça finira par arriver dans ce pays et il
a dit écoutez vos plus personne ne croit
plus en rien dans ce pays
donc on va refaire une constitution qui
va définir comment fonctionne la règle 1
mais c'est vous qui allez décider les
gens aucun de ces élus là donc moi je
fais la même proposition on fait une
assemblée constituante
on peut décider de la façon avec
laquelle on la composent vous pourrez
tirer au sort des gens bon faut quand
même tenir compte du fait qu'il vaut
mieux qu'il y ait des discussions avant
pour qu'on sache pour qu'ils veulent
parce que vous avez des gens qui sont
partisans d'un régime parlementaire
vous en avez d'autres sont partisans
d'un régime présidentiel bon faut quand
même qu'on tranche tout ça mais on nous
ferait une assemblée soit tirée au sort
soit élu mais où il y aurait pas un seul
sortant des autres assemblées des gens
combien m'étais eu à part sans doute au
niveau local parce que ça a le ce niveau
local départemental c'est un bon
entraînement la compréhension des
affaires publiques et souvent les gens
qui sont là ont une connaissance très
fine de plein d'aspects de la réalité
que quand on est d'ailleurs ou connaît
des fois un peu moins bien bon voilà ça
serait l'assemblée constituante est elle
redit qu elle redéfinir est absolument
toutes les règles politiques de
fonctionnement du pays elle remettrait
tout à plat nous avons besoin d'une
remise à plat
la constitution actuelle elle a été
élaborée en 1958
c'était la réponse que le général de
gaulle proposé à la fidh
créé par la précédente république la
quatrième qui était réputé très instable
et surtout il y avait la crise de la
décolonisation
bon on a changé la constitution à donner
plus de pouvoir au président de la
république parce qu'à ce moment là les
gens pensaient que c'était ça qu'il
fallait faire et puis la personnalité du
général de gaulle rassuré parce que il
avait été le chef de la france libre on
sait des choses qui s'oublier pas bons
intervalles réguliers on peut changer la
constitution la france de 1958 et la
france d'aujourd'hui ça pue rien à voir
mais est ce que les gens savent que la
constitution a déjà été changés depuis
1958 25 x dont vingt deux sans qu'on
n'ait rien demandé à personne c'est à
dire aux députés aux sénateurs 3 où les
gens vont pas une tente se rendre quand
par exemple est ce qu'ils savent que
dans l'article 16 de la constitution
on suspend toutes les libertés
démocratiques a pu arriver j'en sais
rien pourquoi enfin bon on est envahi un
bon et on dira c'est pas le monde se
dispute et je ne sais pas comment on
appliquerait l'article 16 a
personnellement je trouve que c'est pas
une bonne idée que cet article 7 mai à
la dernière réforme on l'a dit oui mais
au bout de six mois il faudra rendre des
comptes
réfléchissez les gens ça veut dire que
on peut dans ce pays sur la base d'un
article de la constitution suspend
toutes les libertés pendant six mois
c'est pas rien quand même
la plupart des gens n'en savais rien je
prends cet exemple est ce que vous êtes
toujours d'accord pour que le président
de la république décide de tout aspect
il ya 550 7 550 postes de très hauts
fonctionnaires qui sont à la discrétion
du président de la république trouvez ça
normal puisque c'est ce truc c'est une
monarchie présidentielle
alors il ya des gens qui pensent
toujours y avoir toujours eu ça lorsque
régate ya un chef ça marche mieux
bien sûr qu'il faut qu'il ya une
autorité mais c'est la manière d'exercer
l'autorité qui compte donc c'est le cas
dans lequel on fait c'est ça qu'il faut
bien comprendre si vous dites à un homme
mon gars tu as tout une femme a tous les
pouvoirs
et vous croyez qu'il va rester sans
esprit combien de temps non il faut il
faut qu'un cadre est il faut surtout
faire d'abord confiance au collectif
vous savez ce qui se passe en ce moment
dans
des légions de la plus grosse surprise
de beaucoup d'observateurs c'est que les
gens qui sont engagés dans l'action
disent beaucoup de choses extrêmement
construite il découvre que le peuple
français à un niveau d'instruction et
d'éducation bien supérieur à celui de
toutes les générations précédentes
donc c'est pas vrai que ce peuple ait
besoin d'être mené à la baguette un et
c'est pas vrai qu'ils aient besoin
d'avoir un monarque présidentiel
ça n'existe nulle part ailleurs en
europe et les régimes ne sont pas moins
instable ou que la france ce n'est pas
vrai les allemands n'ont pas ce système
leur système est stable
et quand on me dit ça garantit la
stabilité des pouvoirs publics
et bien vous n'avez qu'à faire les
comptes du nombre de ministre de
l'économie qu'il ya eu depuis dans les
dix dernières années et bien vous allez
voir qu'ils tiennent à peine deux ans ou
un an et demi ce qui vaut à peine ce qui
se passait dans la quatrième république
donc il faut que ce débat là ils soient
mis dans la main des français c'est eux
qui peuvent s'ils le font regarder ce
que ça changerait tout nous on va se
mettre à parler d'elle de l'organisation
des pouvoirs publics c c'est exactement
ce qui est en train de se passer sur les
ronds-points par des gens parlent du
référendum et c'est formidable
j'ai connu un pays on a imprimé des
articles sur les paquets de pâtes pour
que tout le monde puisse en discuter en
famille et à partir de là le peuple se
reconstitue donc ce grand nouveau peuple
de gens qui vivent en ville où les
femmes jouent un rôle qu'elle ne jouais
pas ya cinquante ans ils n'avaient pas
la même
la même présence politique économique
dans la vie du pays
bon et tous ces gens qu avec lesquels on
sait mélanger
voilà la nouvelle france surgir et se
donnerait elle même sa propre définition
il faut faire confiance aux gens faut
arrêter de croire que c'est une masse
qui responsable qui n'est pas capable de
décider comment s'organise la vie
publique seules les très intelligents
sont capables de le faire parce que les
très intelligent voyez dans quel état
ils ont mis ce pays alors c'est pas la
peine d'être si intelligent et d'avoir
fait autant d'études pour qu'on arrive à
ce résultat là bon ya pas une région
qu'on fait beaucoup d'études qui sont
responsables
blé du riz du référendum d'initiative
citoyenne qu'on entend beaucoup qui est
peut-être même la revendication numéro
une actuellement au sein du mouvement
des gilets jaunes
si on devait prendre des exemples pour
lesquelles vous il ya un point d'argent
certains entre la france insoumise et
gilet jaune parce que on sait nous
pousser en tant que journaliste on était
beaucoup sur le terrain donner la parole
à ces gilet jaune et on voit une
multitude de revendications différentes
parfois très varié d'une personne à une
autre
quelles sont celles que la france un
soumises veut porter concrètement en
général en général que vous avez pu
l'entendre déjà de ce que moi j'ai pu
voir il est évident que je me sens très
en phase avec toutes les revendications
qui concerne le partage des richesses
vont changer l'impôt dans ce pays parce
que cette histoire de taxes qui
s'accumulent de tous les côtés d'un
impôt qui est complètement nul
les gens ont raison c'est toujours ça
qu'a provoqué en france des révolutions
n'y a que ceux qui n'hésitent pas les
bouquins d'histoire qui ne savent pas la
révolution de 89 la grande révolution
qui font de la france et qui a changé
l'histoire du monde au point de départ
c'est ça commence par la question des
impôts
ça n'a aucun rapport avec aujourd'hui
chez bien il y avait un roi qui était
pas tout à fait dans la bonne case bon
ça n'a rien à voir avec aujourd'hui il y
avait une dette abyssale et on ne savait
pas comment la payer ça n'a rien à voir
avec aujourd'hui il y avait des
privilégiés qui voulaient pas payer un
bon comme aujourd'hui bref vous avez
compris c'est un clin d'oeil que je fais
l'histoire nous apprend beaucoup de
choses donc le système fiscal français
globalement ça va plus vous avez il
reste encore des paquets de niches
fiscales dont 80% ne profite qu'à 10%
les plus fortunées du pays
vous avez un système d'impôt sur le
revenu vous allez voir à la fin du mois
en iran moins d'impôts à la source
bon vous avez un système d'imposition
sur le revenu ou via que cinq tranches
et écouter les gens que ça c'est un peu
technique
il ya des moments on peut pas faire
autrement il faut expliquer les choses
cinq tranches ça veut dire que quand
vous avez emmené on vous met pas le même
pourcentage pour tout le monde et pour
tout dans il faut que ce soit graduelle
et pour chaque tranche va vous payer
différemment par exemple si vous avez je
prends un exemple absurde 1 si vous avez
10 euros
bon bah c'est si je vous prends 10 %
c'est pas pareil que si vous avez un
vision il faut prendre 10% il va pas
vous manquer les mêmes choses d'accord
donc il ya d'étrange
aujourd'hui on n'a que 5 d'accord donc
les très très riches payent autant que
les petits riches et les classes
moyennes porte ou sur leur dos la moitié
des français payent pas d'impôt du tout
et au milieu ça y va à fond la caisse ça
va pas et moi je propose quand même 14
tranche d'impôt ceux qui gagnent le plus
payent le plus ce gain est loin payent
le moins ce que vient de dire a pas une
invention révolutionnaire de dire les
petits paye petit et les groupes et
heroes il faut que les gros accepte
aussi que ben ils font que tout le monde
quand ils participent ils ont beaucoup
d'argent en tant mieux pour eux en
quelque sorte pas bon parce que fois ce
qu'ils en font mais voilà voilà un
exemple ça c'est des choses sur
lesquelles je comprends ce que disent
les gens et je me sens en phase avec eux
je me sens en phase sur cette histoire
de réorganiser complètement la politique
fiscale du pays parce que tout ce machin
est fait uniquement pour favoriser les
plus les plus puissants après la
commande irla l'imposition des
entreprises
vous voyez bien quelque chose qui tourne
pas rond peut pas imposer les petites
comme les très gros ça n'a rien à voir
sa porte le même nom on appelle ça
entrepris et peut-être que ça fait
plaisir aux gars de se dire je suis
patron mais bon la majorité de ceux qui
s'appellent patron dans ce pays il faut
voir la moyenne de leur salaire en plus
depuis maintenant qui a les auto
entrepreneurs qui ont bien vous êtes
patron de votre propre boîte à bonbons à
tout ça ça c'est un mot mais la réalité
beaucoup plus différente et moi je suis
pour qu'on fasse attention d'abord à
privilégier l'outil de travail donc
l'imposition elle doit d'abord favoriser
l'outil de travail l'investissement et
je suis pas d'accord pour contexte la
même manière dans une société
l'argent qui réinvestit dans la société
pour faire de l'investissement est ce
qui part dans les dividendes ont pas
d'accord et ainsi de suite
donc il faut 2
de nouvelles priorités je pense que de
toute façon pour ce qui est de
l'économie réelle c'est à dire la
production elle-même vraiment un
il va falloir faire un effort
gigantesque gens il faut comprendre ça
il faut qu'on change de manière de
produire de manière de consommer parce
que c'est notre responsabilité de devant
la planète quoi il faut arrêter de
croire que ça mais ça va s'arranger de
s'isoler écologie est entre guillemets
justice fiscale mais c'est très facile à
faire c'était un bon rendu tout ça une
histoire de fous ils ont fait ils ont
fait croire aux gens que l'écologie j'ai
entendu une cote r 1000 fois dans un
reportage
elle était brave à l'arrière sont bien
là sur les genoux et puis elle dit elle
dit écoutez nous l'écologie on est
d'accord moi aussi j'ai des petits là
mais nous on ne peut pas se le payer
comment on peut pas se le payer bien sûr
que si on peut se le payer il faut
absolument qu'on se le paye donc il faut
qu'on change la manière de produire et
les moyens d'investir là dedans c'est
pas d'aller les chercher à la pompe dans
la poche d aider 2,2 du commun des
mortels de cette manière grossière et
vulgaire les gens ils se disent ils
savent qu'ils n'ont pas de goût pour le
le le diesel c'est ils sont pâles bien
ma tendance chic on ramène du diesel on
leur a dit pour neil vielle ça coûte
moins cher et ça marche mieux que si
vous leur proposez d'autres choses il
les prendrons mais à condition pour les
leur donne aux crises et les moyens de
le faire on ne peut pas dire aux gens
changer de voiture et en même temps la
paye est insuffisante le 10 du mois on
sait plus où on va et ainsi de suite ce
n'est pas possible
là on parle du détail c'est-à-dire de la
vie des gens mais pour l'économie elle
même c'est elle qu'il faut organiser on
a besoin écoutez mon à peu près chiffres
et on a besoin d'eux d'une masse de 2
d'argent qu'on connaît qui est lié à aux
engagements qu on appris à la coque 21
qu'augmentait rousset c'est la grande
conférence internationale pour le climat
quatre ans a pris des engagements
personnellement je les trouve
insuffisant et la coque 21 ans c'est
bien elle a existé il ya eu un accord
mondial c'est parfait mais c'est pas
suffisant
sa prévoit 3 degrés demi de plus de
chaleur donc la catastrophe écologique
bas va avoir lieu
et on sait qu'on est en retard d'une les
français ne manque déjà 80
il ya on aurait dû mettre dans le
changement de la production qu'on a déjà
de retard moi j'avais proposé dans mon
programme
j'avais dit écoutez souhait hollande on
a pris un retard de 20 milliards par an
dans les investissements donc je propose
qu'on fasse 100 milliards
d'investissement s'étaient mises à ma
tante sans doute changer les chiffres
bientôt on va passer à l'actualisation
de me chiffres mais on a un projet de
budget alternatif en les gens peuvent le
trouver sur le site de la france ont
soumis tout est calculé en notre très
très bonne équipe la suite bon mais il
faut faire un effort d'investissement
pour changer les machines pour changer
surtout l'accès à l'énergie tout neuf à
comprendre que l'énergie c'est le point
de départ du fonctionnement toute
l'économie
on ne peut pas continuer comme ça avec
les énergies carbonées d'un côté et le
nucléaire qui est super dangereux de
l'autre les gens moi je vous demande
d'entendre ça c'est dangereux tout ça
c'est très dangereux dans l'entente qui
se passe rien on félicite ceux qui font
ceux qui travaillent et qui font en
sorte qu'il ne se passe rien mais
statistiquement ça n'existe pas un
système sans risque tombe bien un
problème bien pour la changer tout ça il
nous faut des dizaines de milliers
d'éoliennes en mer
des dizaines de milliers d'hydroliennes
dans tout ce qui est cool de dos dans
notre pays
donc ça c'est beaucoup d'investissement
chez beaucoup de travail on dit c'est de
la dette
oui alors où est le problème c'est une
d'elles qui est avec avec un capital
avec des machines qui existe qui
produisent quelque chose donc il va
falloir faire sans doute une caisse
différentes pour cette dette là là aussi
il faut arrêter de se faire peur avec
des grands mots langue et la dette la
tête mais des gens écoutent et moi la
dette qu'on à la personne ne paiera
jamais moi je viens faire semblant tout
le monde à caen toulouse comme tous les
économistes libéraux disent bon faut
payer la dette très bien mais elle ne
sera jamais piri trop importantes non
seulement pas en france dans toute
l'europe et dans le monde
et là on parle que de la dette publique
les gens quand vous entendez parler de
la dette vous parle que de la dette
publique mais la dette privée est
beaucoup plus dangereuse il est
supérieur à la dette publique pourquoi
les plus dangereuses parce que l'état
vous le retrouverez toujours il sera
toujours là il y aura toujours les
institutions sont là les biens de l'état
existent en france
le patrimoine commun des français c'est
pas conduire mois 30 milliards c'est
beaucoup d'argent
bon vous me direz c'est des choses à
hollande à bhl ou encore ils arrivent
tous à vendre alors donc qu'il pourrait
maintenant de l'eau la mer elle reste
mais bref il ya un patrimoine
considérable vous retrouverez toujours
l'état et puis quoi qu'il arrive vous
les vrais toujours le matin pour aller
au boulot
il faudra donner à manger aux enfants il
faudra bref l'économie elle tournera mai
et vous trouverez toujours l'état mais
la dette privée elle s'est beaucoup plus
dangereux pourquoi parce que si dans le
droit privé si vous pouvez publier
monsieur ben vous êtes en faillite
vous fermez votre dette s'écroule et
suite il posséder votre type de dette va
s'assoit dessus et ainsi de suite donc
elle et elle est très fragile à
l'échelle du monde
il ya une énorme bulle financière et
madame lagarde la présidente du fmi qui
est pas mal d un souviens c'était même
qui dit ça va mal tourner donc j'ai fait
une proposition pour toute l'europe
autant traiter le problème avant que ça
tourne mal
faisons une conférence de la dette on
peut transférer tous les titres de dette
des états quand titre de dell de la
banque centrale européenne et les états
pourront donc à nouveau se refinancer
premièrement ne me dites pas que ce
n'est pas possible parce que la banque
centrale européenne a déjà racheté des
titres de dette des états aux banques
privées et vous savez ce qui se passe
c'était banques privées veulent pas les
défendre
alors donc tegel en disant heureux où
vous allez à la catastrophe puis
d'autres zones en gamme les titres parce
que vous allez les pays ça c'est le
premier aspect est le deuxième aspect
c'est qu'il faut que les états puissent
emprunter ailleurs que sur le marché
c'est-à-dire qu'il puisse emprunter à la
banque centrale européenne
que nous avons donc il faut qu'elle
arrête d'être une institution qui ne
traite qu'avec le privé il faut que les
états puissent emprunter a très tôt à
des taux très faibles
si vous dites c'est les agences de
notation qui décide ce que vous valez et
cas présent vous mais des taux d'intérêt
dont vous êtes perdus vous êtes à la
merci de ceux qui mettent une note
vous savez qui c'est qui met des notes
des gens qui arrivent en avion il monte
dans le taxi font le tour et à rien il y
jouait la france ça marche pas trop fort
et mettre le feu aux champs elysées
allant dire ya un risque contre le tout
et vous avez un peuple entier qu'elle a
à payer c'est ce qui est arrivé aux
grecs
bien sûr dans mon propos je simplifie je
sais qu'il ya une part de caricatures
1dans dans ce que je dis mais c'est pour
rendre compréhensible ce que nous
pouvons faire moi ce que je veux dire
aux gens c'est que il ya la possibilité
de faire des choses de faire de grandes
choses de belles choses quand je vous
parle de cette transition écologique que
l'état impulserait avec par la
planification écologique
ça veut dire des dizaines de milliers de
postes de travail des belles choses
qu'on invente qu'on fait chaque lan
seront utiles à la collectivité et on a
l'impression d'être un peuple de petits
malheureux carrière de la pointe de
leurs chaussures ya un qui m'a ya rien
qui va c'est pas vrai on peut faire
plein de choses il n'y a pas de fatalité
sauf si on renonce conservant donne et
que on laisse des gens 6e illuminé
idéologiquement que des macros et
compagnie gouvernements ont des horaires
malpel de personnes réagissait sur la
question du riq qu'on évoquait
précédemment qui fait partie des
peut-être même aujourd'hui point numéro
évoquer celle et gilet jaune aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on peut aborder tous les
sujets on sait que voilà il ya eu
certaines polémiques sur le fait de dire
est-ce qu'on peut a évoqué la peine de
mort est ce qu'on peut remettre en cause
le mariage pour tous il y avait des
commentaires dans ce sens là est ce
qu'il ya vraiment des sujets du passé
qui ne peuvent plus revenir sur le
devant de la maison alors d'abord
commençons sur le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne moi je
je suis d'accord avec ça et j'oublie pas
dans que on a proposé le référendum
révocatoire je l'expliquais il ya un
instant le référenceur
proposer des lois et le référendum
abroger des lois
je veux quand même que ceux qui eux
montent en sache qu'on a déjà proposé ça
au parlement et qu'ils peuvent aller
voir qui a voté pour et qui a voté
contre
d'accord qui a voté pour qui a voté
contre ce qui est sûr c'est que ont voté
contre
toute la droite l'extrême droite et la
république en marche et maintenant ils
viennent faire les malins ou disons oui
c'est une idée qui nous intéresse c'est
pas vrai ce qui les intéresse c'est de
repasser leur propre réforme
constitutionnelle qu'ils avaient prévu
de faire et de après avoir fait comme ça
la bouger un peu les mains et les doigts
dans le grand débat qui doit commencer
qui commence très mal puisque la
présidente a déjà commencé par s'en
aller
bon à la fin ils vous posez des
questions présidence
alors maintenant je viens sur le fond
dès qu'on a parlé de référendum vous
avez vu les gens ils viennent ils sont
sournois ils viennent comme ils n'osent
pas dire le puck sarah massier d'abrutis
on peut quand même pas leur faire
confiance ils viennent comme sands oui
mais alors il ya des sujets comme si par
exemple peuvent français je prends cet
exemple oui je vais je vais vous
répondre très précisément comme si le
prop français il rêvait que d'une chose
rétablir la peine de mort il rêvait que
d'une chose abolir le droit au mariage
pour tous
il rêvait que d'une chose je sais pas
quoi tout ce que vous voudrez d'accord
mais enfin bon ok vous prenez les gens
le croient les gens sont stupides qu'ils
n'ont pas réfléchi l'ont pas mûri avec
leur temps vous croyez que le pouvoir
doit se méfier baïonnette au canon du
peuple tout ça est absurde alors via le
programme existe quand même
donc disons nous les choses franchement
et tranquillement on craint que sur
certains sujets qu'on considère comme
fondamentaux en référendum d'initiative
citoyenne renverse une principe en
principe que nous croyons sacré bon bain
très bien voilà la question est posée
comment il répond tout bon d'abord il
faut savoir une chose au dessus de la
constitution d'abord au dessus de toutes
les lois et à la constitution au dessus
de toutes nos lois
il ya les accords internationaux en à
parier même mot latin ça fait je veux
dire comme ça ça ça va nous détendre
pacta sunt servanda ça veut dire que
toutes les lois sont soumises aux
accords entre
la france a signé elle obligée
d'appliquer bon ou alors elle sortir la
non semble de choses en bien donc je
vous dis ça pour quoi pour vous dire il
ya déjà des niveaux au dessus de la loi
au dessus de la loi la constitution et
au dessus de la constitution sk quelque
chose oui la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen nous croyons que
si quelque chose dans la constitution
était contraire aux droits de l'homme et
du citoyen faudrait l'abroger dans
l'acide dans la constitution et les
citoyens auraient le droit de se
révolter contre un pouvoir qui
appliquerait une chose de contraire aux
droits de l'homme et du citoyen et les
gens faisaient bien entendu droits de
l'homme et du citoyen en général on
oublie le citoyen alors on ferait mieux
de dire aujourd'hui droit de l'être
humain et des citoyens de manière à ne
pas genre et les mots mais c'est ça que
ça veut dire alors on pourrait décider
on pourrait décider ce à dire écoutez
voilà il ya une série de questions qui
sont au dessus de la loi au dessus de la
constitution au niveau des droits de
l'homme à tangible ans de régime on peut
plus y toucher et ce serait telle telle
ou telle question pourquoi on peut le
faire parce que dans la déclaration de
1789 la liberté de disposer de son corps
ça venait pas de sens le droit à
l'avortement qu'on évoque rarement le
droit à l'avortement doit être mis à ce
niveau c'est en droit de propriété de
soi après vous faites ce que vous voulez
je les dires millions de fois aux gens
sont contre l'avortement le comprendre
je peux comprendre qu'ils soient contre
l'avortement
c'est une affaire de personnel mais
chacun décide
d'accord et donc vous n'avez pas droit
d'imposer à quelqu'un de faire ce qu'il
n'a pas envie de faire par exemple de
porter un enfant dans certaines
conditions on est d'accord sur cet
exemple on comprend bien on pourrait
mettre dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen et on dirait la
déclaration on n'y touche plus on
pourrait prendre la même chose pour la
peine de mort on a signé un accord
international on peut décider mais tout
ça va pas tout mettre là-dedans mais on
peut prendre comme ça une série de
questions la question du mariage pour
tous c'est pas c'est pas la question du
mariage qui me posait c'est la question
de l'égalité
le mariage pour tous a jamais voulu dire
qu'on en oublierait les gens se marier
non que je sache que ce soit
des couples hétérosexuels ou des couples
homosexuels
l'union libre ça existe dans notre pays
où l on a même inventé un statut
intermédiaire le pacs nous en parle avec
d'autant plus de plaisir que le premier
run qui a proposé un texte de loi sur le
sujet c'est moi d'accord en 1991 et je
ne défendrai pas un intérêt personnel je
suis hétérosexuel
je défends des l'égalité des droits et
ensuite ça s'est merveilleusement
accompli des gens ont su faire ce qu'il
fallait prendre les bonnes décisions et
ainsi de suite devant pas revenir là
dessus la question qui est posée celle
de l'égalité
pas celle de la nature des relations
affectives entre les gens ou leur
orientation sexuelle
c'est donc la liberté d'être à égalité
mais personne n'est obligé de le faire
je trouve qu'il ya quelque chose de
choquant dans le comportement de ceux
qui veulent imposer aux autres une
manière de faire de vivre des v2 de de
ressentir les choses ça c'est alors vous
voyez bien que ça ne concerne pas tous
les domaines de l'existence sa manière
de répartir l'impôt c'est pas tout à
fait la même question que cesse de
disposer de la liberté de son corps de
de la propriété de son corps pour une
femme c'est pas c'est pas de même nature
dans un secteur on touche aux droits
fondamentaux dans l'autre on parle de
l'organisation de la vie de la société
on peut avoir 50 idées moi je vous ai
dit alors quels sont les miennes
vous pouvez avoir un gars qui vient qui
dit ça c'est des folies monsieur au fond
c on connaît votre histoire pendant un
siècle et demi chaque fois qu'un gars
comme moi par les mots amicaux vous
parler monsieur mélenchon l'égalité
n'existe pas des petits ya des grands
les gros il est maigre et les
intelligents et qu'ils sont bêtes
existent pas donc vous voulez faire un
régime politique basée sur l'égalité et
ça sera toujours une violence contre la
nature bien joué c'était leurs arguments
c'est pourquoi c'est en france que sont
nées les idéologies égalitaire avec la
grande révolution et les idéologie
inégalitaire et fascisante sa hausse en
vente - mais c'est quand même chez nous
que ça a commencé
donc vous voyez ce sont ces principes
donc arrêtons de nous faire
peur et surtout de me faire peur d'une
manière malsaine qui est avoir l'air de
sous-entendre que le peuple ne veut que
de mauvaises choses des choses brutales
d'une grossière des choses agressive
ce n'est pas vrai voilà ayons confiance
en nous mêmes on est capable de gérer un
changement constitutionnel et un
référendum d une manière tranquille quoi
on parlait du riq ça me permet de
rebondir un discours de françois ruffin
qu'il avait tenus avec votre groupe
parlementaire où il prend la référence
avec etienne chouard alors on se
souvient un peu ça a été un peu voilà on
doit être derrière un peu des regards un
peu de surprises c'était pas vous trahir
bah moi je suis président d'un groupe
dans lequel il n'y a que des fortes
têtes et forte personnalité mon moi même
j'ai mon caractère
donc mon rôle à moi c'était un ensemble
de faire en sorte qu'on puisse tout en
acheter groupe est bon pas monter au
rideau pour une virgule un adjectif
angoula on a eu un problème parce que on
s'y attendait pas à ce que françois qui
est un bon député qui est un travailleur
qui est quelqu'un qui apporte beaucoup à
tout le groupe je veux le dire au
préalable qu'un esprit une manière
d'être
comme tous les autres chacun a son style
mais là franchement bon n'était pas très
content
alors lui françois il faut aussi lui
poser la question pourquoi il a dit ça
avec lui je vous le dirais pas ça c'est
le secret du pas du professional futur
du président de go pourrait suivre
raconte toutes mes discussions on peut
plus vivre bonnier vaut plus rien dire
on dirait qu'elle est racontée à la télé
bon donc je danse j'arrive je pleure je
parle avec tout le monde et avec lui
spécialement beaucoup parce que nous
sommes amis je prends le compte des amis
qu'on partage beaucoup de goût qui a par
exemple je te raconter un truc comme
j'ai parlé de drew est d'accord et j'ai
fait la comparaison avec le trou et de
la grande révolution ont l'occasion d'y
revenir faudra maintenant juste semaine
françois sûr je connaissais drouet je
connais bien mon histoire de la
révolution
mais le gars qui m'a offert un bouquin
sur deux roues et c'est françois ruchon
on partage beaucoup de choses comme ça
alors quand il a dit ça valait vraiment
tombé comme tout le monde mais enfin ce
monsieur choir quand même quoi c'est pas
nous c'est quelqu'un qui a des positions
liées à des secteurs de l'extrême droite
à la réponse de françois c'est à dire
non mais ça il a changé et françois élu
le croit donc bien penser que ben moi
moi je suis méfiant en tout cas ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que le groupe en
collectif et pas dans l'idée monsieur
choir a changé voilà et puis après moi
ya aussi quelque chose qui commence à me
chauffer c'est que l'on me dit oui mais
c'est lui qui a inventé le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne non mais c'est
quoi encore autre chose peut-être non
non non ce n'est pas vrai nous portons
cette idée depuis très longtemps dans ma
famille politique dans le combat que je
mène depuis des années
voilà et notamment le référendum
révocatoire ça c'est signé france
insoumise le droit de révoquer un élu et
pardon je veux juste y assister un
instant mais rendez vous bien content
nous nous essayons d'apporter des
réponses concrètes aux problèmes qui se
posent comment on fait pour avoir des
institutions stables et en pouvoir
d'intervention populaire permanent au
rebond les gens regardent ailleurs ou
d'hébron vers la prochaine fois non
c'est maintenant qu'il faut répondre
c'est un sac répond idée du référendum
révocatoire et à la stabilité des
institutions mais à tous
le peuple décider de changer une
personne qui est affecté à une tâche
voilà pourquoi je crois pas que monsieur
choir soit si important que ça en tout
cas c'est pas ce que je peux dire à tout
le monde c'est pas la référence de la
france sont soumises dont on parlait
justement de françois ruffin
certains le voient comme peut-être un
successeur après tout de suite à jean
luc mélenchon
pourquoi pas moi moi je sais quel est
mon travail mon travail ça a été de
faire comparé dont les gens vous allez
comprendre parce que moi j'ai passé ma
vie à ça je croise un homme de gauche
au départ j'ai fait tout ça mon trajet
là-dedans gpara des fois on me dit vous
êtes de gauche tu dois t'arrêter quoi
vous nous c'est ce qui suit ce que je
pense de manière d'être on peut lire
mais libre et le ce que je jean-karl
dans l'histoire enfin ce à quoi j'ai
participé avec plein de gens qui portent
un nom dans l'histoire longue alors mais
fondamentalement c'est l'humanisme c'est
à dire un courant philosophique qui est
né au 14e siècle en europe et qui dit le
siège de la vérité dans l'esprit des
êtres humains et débrouillez vous avec
ça et il n'y a pas de pouvoir autre que
celui que vous délibéré entrevoir du
mieux la société politique et tout
moi je me considère comme un enfant de
la grande révolution de 80 m d'accord
qu'est ce qui se passe dans toute
l'europe par tout ce à quoi manger
j'ai appartenu deux de tout mon coeur la
gauche est en miettes détruites
les partis communistes tous détruits les
parties sociales et subclaquant ou
carrément alliée à la politique de
droite est l'exemple le plus typique
c'est ce beau pays qu'est l'italie où on
avait le plus grand parti communiste
d'europe occidentale et c'est tout s'est
effondré
donc moi je me suis dit c'est maintenant
que je dois agir et en 2008
le hasard a fait que il y avait beaucoup
de choses qui bougent et dans le monde
pour construire de nouvelles forces
politiques et moi j'ai rencontré d'abord
une personne assez magique et madame
marie george buffet et on s'est vite
compris et entendus on on a proposé
ensemble avec d'autres parce que la
ch'tite de nom
nous étions nombreux dont plusieurs que
vous continuez à avoir comme corbières
coquerel qui sont des parmi les
fondateurs de cette denrée gens qui
m'entourent on a créé ça et puis on a
porté une première candidature
présidentielle
incroyable 11% alors qu'on bosse j'ai
commencé un trois et demi on s'est dit
ce type est bizarre trois emmy 11 et la
deuxième fois pareil et on termine
presque ben donc vincent tout un
troisième par tout le monde tout le
monde pense là on est au seuil du
pouvoir des macros nice ça n'existerait
pas comme ça contre nous s'ils pensaient
qu'on était rien
évidemment être de ceux dont ils ont le
plus la trouille c'est de nous parce que
nous sommes le parti yeux le mouvement
du partage non plus on a inventé des
choses on n'est plus un parti on est un
mouvement c'est compliqué et je laboure
irritant c'est la certitude que vous
porterez est la france est soumise en
2022 alors je sais que c'est loin que
quoi qu'on porterait à francin soumise à
la présidence il n'avait il y aura un
candidat à une candidature de la france
insoumise en 2009 2 mais on verra je si
vous voulez moi ça va ma gloire est à
son comble savage sont en bonne santé
mais enfants vont bien des bouquins se
vendent bien
j'ai fait tout mon boulot de tout mon
coeur avec toute ma force toute mon
énergie
on est arrivé à 20 mais c'est pas moi le
l'important l'importance et j'ai on a
réussi à mettre en mots au programme
politique qui est unique au nom de les
autres copies dans l'avenir en commun et
c'est ça qu'on va porter là nous avons
dit c'est lé député
vous avez vu le nombre de gens qui sont
capables d'être des gouvernants de ce
pays je peux vous en citer disent bien
comme françois ruffin pour être un bon
président évidemment et puis coquerelles
et puis corbières et puis matt hill
panneaux et puis je ne s'appelle pas pas
excusez moi les camarades parce que si
je récite la liste des 10 mg à tous les
coups sans oublier un puits à ce vous
voyez à l'assemblée nationale puis à
ceux qui vont être élus au parlement
européen il ya tout ce que que qui sont
là les lehmann aubry les manuels bon
parler toute cette liste de gens
ils sont là younousse omarjee vous
l'avez vu débuter de la réunion
brillantissime et combien d'autres donc
chaque rond-point taylorisés par rapport
à françois ruffin parce qu'il est
énormément vu depuis le début de cette
crise et j'ai joué un peu moins ces
derniers jours un peu plus en retrait
parce que il est en train de faire ce
film décrit rambo peint à l'huile a de
la chance qui peut se retirer comme ça
bah oui on a fait cette annonce c'est
bien c'est bien que son nom était mis en
scène dans le grès t qui soit un peu
cavalier seul on avait pu vient parfois
non mais ça c'était histoire
vous savez c'est comme ceux qui disent
que alors gênant de fer que je tiens le
mouvement le seul groupe parlementaire
dans lequel il ya une pluralité de
représentation politique c'est le mien
d'accord si j'étais là brut qu'on dit il
y aurait déjà plus de 2 du groupe
écoutez j'ai une communiste en mon
groupe trois membres d'un groupe que
vous connaissez peut-être pas qu'ils
s'appellent ensemble c'est le parti de
gauche et les autres ils n'ont pas
disons 10 appartenait à aucun parti
donc c'est le mouvement c'est pareil
c'est pas en partie à des gens toutes
sortes la liste convient de présenter et
dont on a confié et heureusement qu'elle
a accepté on est on est 50 ans à la main
non aubry c'est quelqu'un qui vient pas
ni dans party vient elle vient d'une
association où elle mène une bataille
sur ça qui nous attirait les yeux contre
la fraude fiscale à l'échelle européenne
et pour l'égalité fiscale
donc c'est une fille kane super capacité
d' expertise bon il ya beaucoup de deux
de gens qui vont apparaître et là ma
fierté à moi c'est d'avoir constitué
cette force est de pouvoir vous dire
écoutez vous dépendez plus jean luc
mélenchon vous avez 17 personnes qui
sont là vous en aurez d'autres
donc vous allez vous allez pouvoir vous
déployez parce que ce que nous avons
représenté dans le temps et dans
l'histoire va continuer dans ce pays
et heureusement parce que c'est la
france qui a une tradition
révolutionnaire droits de l'homme il ya
une tradition républicaine
révolutionnaire et que nous incarnons
alors quand on dit vous êtes contre les
institutions je le répète oui je suis
pour la 6ème république par l'a5 et un
bon dieu c'est un droit
pratique vous voyez c'est ça ma fierté
alors à ploujean serait moi je n'en sais
rien monsieur et il faut avoir la la
modestie l'humilité de remercier le jour
qui est passé pour la voir passer si on
a employés utilement et de se dire que
ce sera un bienfait
si le jour suivant est une occasion de
le prouver qu'on peut se rendre utile et
il faut savoir le faire à la place qu'on
est prêt à se donner je ne sais pas vous
dire je n'ai pas eu peur de reprises
d'être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle mais je connais les
limites qui dans la vie de tout temps
une toutes femmes peuvent se dresser
devant soi j'ai perdu mon meilleur ami
et mon bras droit qui est mort à 44 ans
et que je pleure encore et qui était
l'homme dont je pensais qu'il était en
situation d'incarner la suite des
événements
depuis j'ai acquis une forme d'humilité
je me dis nous verrons bien mais je suis
si fier d'avoir au moins comme reconnais
ça j'ai au moins fait ça et je les fais
avec encore deux doctrines qui est
cohérent et une vision du monde qui est
cohérente ya un programme
il ya une doctrine l'ère du peuple vous
pouvez acheter 3 euros en librairie
il existe toujours si vous le trouvez
s'il en reste bref et de magnifiques
équipe
regardez bien les députés la france en
somme ils y sont arrivés se
connaissaient même pas entre 1 on a tenu
le choc
deux sessions dont deux sessions
extraordinaires bref on aurait pu
s'écrouler en route
là c'est ce que vous voyez nos
collaborateurs une équipe magique
tous ces gens là maintenant ils savent
faire je vous garantis qu'il faut
gouverner le pays demain il ya de quoi
faire un gouvernement et même plusieurs
avec le nombre de jean-pierre donc je
n'ai pas de être content que quelqu'un
apparaît et ben je suis content quand on
me dit ah mais françois méchain bravo on
me dit matt hill panneau quand elle a
fait ça te tout ce travail qu'elle a
fait sur le nucléaire elle fait une
vidéo il ya 5 millions personnes qui la
voient alors fait 2e 5 millions un
nouveau journaliste est ce que ça veut
dire
5 millions je sais pas
oui c'est bien un monstre je vois
coquerel des jours et des jours dans
l'hémicycle avec sa vivre ou un mot
d'amour qu'on veut faire le projet de
contre budget wahou
comme ils sont forts comme ils sont
beaux comme ils sont grands vont suivre
et j'ai fait mon boulot
alors après ce qui m'arrive à moi de me
verront bien mais moi je n'ai pas
l'intention de de rentrer à la maison -
c'est pas mon projet dans la vie jusqu'à
mon dernier souffle je serai un
combattant et mon dernier souffle c'est
pas pour tout de suite rassurez vous
pour pour ceux que ça inquiète ça finira
par arriver je suis un peu je suis en
train de plagier général de gaulle où je
vais vous prendre en traître
ils disaient qu'ils disent est bon vous
inquiétez pas ça finira par s'arrêter
mais franchement c'est pas le sujet du
jour rien la question qui se pose
beaucoup par rapport à eux au pacifisme
par rapport à la violence
ouais on entend beaucoup parler même
parfois sur le terrain on voit là nous
dans le direct on donna pas obliger les
jours et on entend parfois certains qui
vont dire le micro très directement s'il
n'y avait pas eu des tensions comme il y
en a eu début décembre
macron n'aurait jamais lâché 10
milliards
quelques jours plus tard ça veut dire
est ce que pour vous un parmi eux qu'on
vous est ce que pour vous on n'obtient
rien sans tension tensions et violences
tortures viols à rien bon d'abord ce que
vous dites est vrai je veux dire je
confirmerai vrai je confirme ce n'est
pas mon avis c'est lorsqu'on envoie
l'inter je mets en garde
je viens c'est un vrai débat qu'on aille
convoi même parfois au sein même des
forums de discussion des gilets jaunes
où certains se disent mais ce week-end
il faut voilà le le pacifique ça suffit
il faut passer à autre chose et ce que
vous en tant que responsable politique
vous comprenez la violence de certains
l'homme la comprendre c'est une chose et
je vais vous répondre sans détour mais
d'abord je veux confirmer que j'ai
entendu les mêmes choses que vous je
vais même rendre encore plus inquiet je
conserve que
l'appréciation de la place de la
violence a changé c'est à dire que il ya
dix ans on aurait été unanimes à ou de
près pour dire pas question aujourd'hui
c'est plus compliqué il faut expliquer
il faut raisonner
moi je veux donner mon explication de
dirigeants politiques
je peux d'abord donné une explication
qui serait philosophique ou morale je
pense que la non violence est la
solution rationnelle raisonnable
humaniste fondamentale je ne dis pas que
vous savez c'est comme le rapport à
l'alimentation 1
je dis pas que après tout dans tous mes
actes on est senti qu'un homme qui
serait obsédée de non violence
je suis pas un saint je suis pas le
mahatma gandhi il n'y rien de tout ça
mais je pense que c'est ça qu'il faut
faire c'est qu'il faut essayer de faire
comme tous dans la vie on a rallié brin
de faire comme si que comme ça bon donc
la non violence
à mes yeux est la stratégie fondamentale
de relations humaines
il faut essayer de mettre en meurent
maintenant dans l'arène politique
je veux parler avec sérieux et
détermination de cette question j'ai eu
une longue vie de militant j'ai vu
beaucoup de choses j'ai cru à une époque
que la violence joue un rôle dans
l'histoire et qu'on pouvait comment dire
non seulement l'instrumentaliser mais
que les choses aient partie de ce qui
était nécessaire
tout le monde sait que quand parce que
ça c'est beaucoup dit que ma vie a été
beaucoup raconté quand j'étais un jeune
homme de 20 ans étudiant j'étais dans le
militant trop triste on trouve ce qui
est le fondateur de l'armée rouge
inutile de vous dire que ça avait de
l'influencé sur notre manière de nous
représenter le monde
j'en profite pour condamner formellement
la série des flics trotsky qui voulaient
du tout mais bon oui puisque au monde à
cette histoire les américains ils sont
incroyables il a réclamé
donc je
j'ai connu aussi la période où on
pensait que comme le che c'était en
faisant des révolutions armée qu'on
arrivait au pouvoir le tce en est mort
je ne le dis pas pour le charger parce
que au fond il est mort d'avoir cru en
ses idées mais je veux vous dire nous
avons été au bout de cette histoire là
partout où il ya eu de la violence
ça a toujours mal fini pour nous pour
notre famille pour notre pour le camp
des ceux qui sont pour l'égalité pour le
partage et c'est tout le temps les
exceptions il ya toujours des exceptions
une règle il ya eu quelques petites
exceptions cuba au début
1 c'est tout donc la violente tourne
toujours contre nous même quand il
paraît qu'elle soit comment dire qu'elle
était évidente par exemple la lutte
armée contre pinochet on pourrait dire
avec autres en dictateur qu'il faut le
faire
ben c'est pas comme ça qu'on l'a vaincu
donc dans le moment qui nous qui nous
occupe lui demande
je vais prendre des exemples plus proche
de nous parce que là j'ai parlé de
piocher ça peut paraître loin pour la
jeune génération
5h20 pouzolles et ne regardent peut-être
cinq sites web et pour ce qu'il quitte
plus contemporain la tunisie en tunisie
mes amis sont au front populaire
tunisien leurs responsables politiques
le plus connu et hamma hammami qui a été
candidat à l'élection présidentielle qui
a fait un peu plus de 10% des bois quand
la révolution a éclaté la révolution
citoyenne en tunisie que ben ali a été
chassé il ya eu une période avec une
constituante il fallait pour écrire donc
qu'ils ont choisi la bonne méthode des
tunisiens faire une constituante et
c'était très tendu
on importe politique était très tendue
le parti
les partis religieux avait ces
extrémistes il supportait personnes et
comptait faire une constitution
religieuses en tunisie les tunisiens ne
voulait pas et il ya eu des morts c'est
à dire qu'on nous a tué jeudi nous parce
que je m'identifie à des amis des hommes
comme chokri belaid où mohamed brahmi
qui ont été assassinés donc grosse
question à ce moment là écoutez moi je
nomme et vous autres c'est pas tout de
faire des phrases ou général faut
assumer la responsabilité des actes qui
suivent
qu'est ce qu'on fait vous croyez que les
camarades ont pas parlé entre eux ils
sont diane ils ont tué deux on a rendu 4
pour leur montrer qu'on ne se laissera
pas faire
et ben non c'est pas ça qu'ils ont
décidé ils ont dû en tuera personne on
continue le processus même si on est le
dos au mur
choukri belaïd a été tué en bas de chez
lui devant sa cité hlm
mohamed brahmi devant sa porte d'accord
les les épouses de ces deux hommes là
qui sont des militantes politiques ont
mené une lutte implacable pour que la
bataille continue dans sa forme
démocratiques de masse deux masses
écoutez moi chaque fois que vous passez
à la violence
vous réduisez le nom de ceux qui
viennent dans la lutte parce que ça fait
peur parce qu'on peut plus venir en
famille parce que ceux qui courent pas
assez vite ne viennent pas donc vous
rabougri c'est la base de ce que je suis
en train de vous dire c'est d'abord une
question de stratégie politique de
lignes d'orientation générale plus le
monde dans la lutte plus les esprits
mûrissent plus tout le monde comprend
les enjeux de la lutte si la lune se
réduit à ceux qui sont capables de
courir vite et de frapper fort ça fera
plus grand monde à la fin et surtout à
la france a plus personne parce que
c'est une escalade sans fin alors je
sais que les gens vont dire vous aussi
m'ont dit pas d'accord tu nous dises âme
en attendant si on n'avait pas fait tout
ce qu'on a fait on aurait pas eu autant
d'argent dans seul coup je ne crois pas
les gens écoutent et moi c'est pas la
violence qui a fait peur à maquereau la
violence à la rangée d'une certaine
manière vous savez aussi bien que moi
qui a eu le plus d'une situation tout à
fait bizarroïde où les gens les laisser
arriver à un endroit puis l'ena c'est
bon
on sait clairement on avait l'impression
qu'on utilisait ont instrumentalisé la
police et les cortèges au service d'une
attente dans la pression que cette
violence finalement mais écoutez ça
allez vous devant la télé comprenez vous
ils passent leurs journées à faire de la
propagande pour expliquer que nous
sommes tous des violents des abrutis et
c'est donc je vous dis qu elle est
maligne après vous doivent très bien ce
que vous voulez c'est moi qui vous
disent que vous allez faire un bon vous
faites bien comme vous voulez jusqu'à
présent mais si vous me demandez mon
avis les gens je vous le donne pas d'
escalade
plus on est nombreux si on est une masse
immense combien que nos gosses et tout
le web en tapant ce moment parce que
c'est un peu tendu mais il faut qu'on
soit une massivement c'est le nombre
c'est ça qui fait peur à mâcon
c'est le fait que quoi qu'on vous phare
nous est la semaine suivante vous rendez
compte ce pays est gouverné depuis
maintenant huit semaines par des
gouvernants qui chaque semaine se
demande qui va se passer à la fin de la
semaine un seul pays au monde est comme
ça la france
bon c'est ça qui leur fait peur le
nombre la masse les gens déterminés gens
simples des gens qui jusque là faisait
pas de politique et j'ai confiance dans
votre nombre dans votre force c'est
comme ça que vous allez finir par avoir
le dernier mot
ils ne peuvent pas gouverner contre le
peuple ils ne peuvent pas et si le
peuple et toute la semaine
toutes les semaines dans la rue eh ben
il ya un moment où ils sont obligés de
dire bon bah retour à la case départ
les carottes sont cuites on vote nous
évoquait justement twilight en flip qui
était sur tf1 tout à l'heure enfin à
l'aise en début de semaine par dont il
était retourné sur tf1
c'était en début de semaine donc avec
plusieurs mesures que tu es annoncé
notamment le fait que samedi il y aurait
80 mille policiers efforts des membres
des forces de l'ordre sur le territoire
dépassant 5000 à paris et puis notamment
également des nouvelles mesures pour
durcir certaines situations notamment
les non-déclarations manifestation des
évolutions en matière de maintien de
l'ordre
vous c'est quoi votre positionnement
j'imagine que vous avez écouté
attentivement le premier bien sûr qu'est
ce que vous en pensez l'avoir gêné gars
qui croyait pas lui-même à ce qu'ils
disaient parce qu'il sait de d'edouard
philippe c'est pas macron bon c'est ce
sont deux hommes de droite mais macron
sais tu sais il est jamais rien fait
d'autre que ça il était dans une banque
après il était je sais pas quoi il s'est
retrouvé mini mini du budget se retrouve
président de la république ait jamais
rien fait d'autre que ça bon il connaît
rien au peuple français ce pas le cas ne
s'est pas le cas du premier ministre
edouard philippe lui était maire d'une
ville dont qui sait bien comment il fait
la france sait bien que sa semaine pas
la baguette et à coups de trique bon
donc alors ils ont et ont fini par le
convaincre d'aller à la télévision a
raconté qu'il va durcir le labousse
c'est pitoyable si vous voulez sur le
plan intellectuel
ça fait pitié parce que c'est quand même
un esprit c'est brillant monsieur
edouard philippe sabo est un adversaire
que quand même le dire un tas un petit
bryant a plutôt et vous le voyez
expliqué mettre sur le même plan à la
télévision un droit constitutionnel
qu'est le droit de manifester les gens
pour comprendre qu'il ya des gens qui
disent ouais manifestez vous nous faites
suer peut-être bien mais ça s'appelle la
démocratie donc manifester c'est un
droit constitutionnel fait partie des
libertés et il met ça sur le même plan
que le comportement de ce qu'on appelle
les hooligans dans les stades de foot
bon enfin écoutez ça n'a rien à voir
avoir le droit au nom d'exprimer une
opinion politique à une opposition au
gouvernement ait le droit d'aller
regarder ou non un match de foot tout et
n'importe qui quand on le présente comme
jeu
le fer arrive à comprendre que c'est pas
de même nature donc on aime un numéro à
la télé de scrogneugneu un beau dire
c'est comme avant t'avais qu'à faire
avant pourquoi tu disais pas arriver
avant pourquoi ils sont pas arrivés
pourquoi parce que les policiers
n'étaient pas bons ils ont fait leur
boulot non qu'est ce qui ne va pas ce
qui va pas c'est qu'une masse de gens
veux pas de votre politique c'est ça le
problème
au départ le problème de l'ordre public
c'est un problème social il n'y a pas
d'ordre public sans justice sociale et
je vais même plus vous dire pour un
républicain un ordre public sans en
justice sociale il est suspect voilà on
peut quand même dire les choses comme
elles sont donc monsieur le premier
ministre a parlé pour faire peur pour
impressionner mais tout ça de tout ça
n'a pas grand sens et je vais vous dire
si vous réfléchissez à l'aspect
juridique des choses qu'on déclare une
manifestation c'était le cas samedi
dernier
normal pourquoi pas tendance à me garder
pour être avec ceux qui le regardent
la manifestation entre les
champs-elysées la place de la bourse a
été a fait l'objet d'une déclaration
préfecture et celle entre l'hôtel de
ville et l'assemblée nationale a fait
l'objet non pas de discussions mais d'un
courrier envoyé en disant on va faire
tel parcours n'y a pas eu une
autorisation entente
et voilà donc vous êtes en train de
plaider pour l'autorisation de calabre
du droit de manifester je ne plais de
rien et que je suis juste on en parle
avec les gens qui vient d'être factuel
moi je veux juste simplement par écrit
c'est bien comme ça vous avez bien
préciser les gens dormaient ce qui est
clair c'est que les gilets jaunes dans
cette affaire sont de bonne foi
j'en dis bon vallée de l'aa là où il
l'avait dit il alors déclaré il allait
bien il avait déclaré
mais dans ce pays il n'ya pas
d'autorisation préalable celle inverse
c'est l'autorité publique dit quoique ce
que voulait faire ça va pas on n'est pas
d'accord on vous dit pourquoi
enfin bon ça on n'est pas un troupeau
gardé par parle pas pars pas je ne sais
pas quel gendarmes c'est pas comme ça
que ça se passe
une vie démocratique des manifs en j'en
ai vu des centaines cependant qui les
organisent je sais comment ça se passe
on discutait qu'a prise avec le préfet
pour savent pas ce dans une ambiance
plutôt décontractée
en général ce sont les autorités qui
disent pas a coûté fait pas à passer par
un tel endroit pas une bonne idée
nous on pense que vous devez pas le
faire passer plutôt là souvent ça se
négocie 1 les parcs au saas est entre
gens de bonne intelligence mais siiii
nationale s'étaient risqués c'était à
j'en sais rien c'est eux qu'on pas voulu
c'est pas les gilets jaunes is on y va
attendait monsieur allons au bout d'eux
puisque wii est factuel donc il envoie
la lettre et après qu'est ce qu'ils font
les attend dans la maison qu'on leur
dise oui pas de réponse qui ne dit mot
consent
on y va ils ont cru de bonne foi qui
pouvait y aller tout d'un coup on les
empêche de passer donc ils sont dix
c'est pas normal c'est pas c'est pas
l'habitude de nos relations
voilà ce qui va pas bon et puis
maintenant je vais aller au fond de la
faire mesdames et messieurs les
manifestations ne peuvent pas être
soumises à autorisation préalable
alors vous allez voir tous les
organismes internationaux et vous
répondront tous la même chose que le
droit de manifester est un droit
fondamental des libertés humaines voilà
on peut discuter ça à dire on n'est pas
d'accord
la liberté ça commence à bien faire et
tout mais ça c'est des grands débats
philosophiques qui nous occupe depuis
deux siècles et il faut se coller son
crâne que c'est nous qui avons gagné
parce que l'un déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen elle s'impose à la
terre entière il n'existait pas avant la
révolution 81 eur c'est une victoire
politique et donc politiquement la
liberté de manifester ne peut pas être
soumises à autorisation préalable
elle peut être soumise
une interdiction au nom des risques de
l'ordre public dûment énoncé signifié et
démontrer voilà pas le caprice de
quelqu'un ou j'étais pas répond du tac à
attendre toi et tes dix mille copains
que je te répondent oui pour pouvoir
sortir de l'enfer que sa patience donc
le dans les événements qui ont lieu les
déclarations après du premier ministre
n'ont pas grande signification ce qui
est d'abord pour la raison que tout ce
qu'il a dit ne s'appliquera pas samedi
prochain ni sa fille d'après ni samedi
d'après ni samedi la fin du long terme
tout simplement parce qu'il faut quand
même il ya un parlement dans ce pays il
faut quand même bien avec votre
permission a quand même bon discuter au
moins qu'ils disent qu'on est ce sur
quoi on n'est pas d'accord
toutes les organisations comment dire
liés à la défense des droits de l'homme
disent vous êtes fou que ça va trop loin
et surtout ça n'explique pas comment
dire ce n'est pas l'insuffisance de la
sanction qui crée la tension c'est parce
qu'il ya la tension quand on est dans
cette situation parce que des milliers
de gens disent nous ne voulons pas c'est
un problème politique pas un problème
d'ordre public et encore une fois le
problème d'ordre public ne serait rien
que dans le cadre de la justice sociale
et de la justice démocratique parce que
oui c'est vrai au début les gens parler
de surtaxe de carburant et maintenant il
parle de référendum d'initiative le
citoyenne elle va alors qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ce qui s'est passé se disent
pas dans tous les pays du monde
quand une situation sociale est bloquée
elle devient une situation politique et
les gens dire m'écouter qui vous aide
pour nous dire non alors pouvoir
répondre qu' on est con et les gens qui
ont été élus cdh estime mme ils ont
raison de le dire
c'est vrai et puis les au 10 mai nous on
est le peuple alors c'est pourquoi je
dis à la fin quand on en arrive là on
vote là en ce moment dans quoi on est
une situation de tension incroyable
entretenue par le pouvoir et tous ses
larbins qui ont fait de déchets les
jaunes une barre associés via la rente
et cerexhe et j'espère que samedi
prochain le 20 sept
ils ont prévu de faire une grande
manifestation du parti de l'autorité
alors moi je vous dis à vous autres les
français tous écoutés
quand quelqu'un vient vous parler
d'autorité comme ça ça finit toujours
très mal ça finit par de l'autoritarisme
l'autorité ça se conquiert
ça se mérite ça se gagne ça se fait par
des tas de choses où il faut pas être
comme une mule obstiné sur certains
sujets des fois ça coûte lorsque vous
croyez à quelque chose de bon pas le
moment ça passe pas ça passe pas ils
vont retourner devant les gens discuter
expliqué compléter monsieur monsieur
mâcon qui s'est mis dans une situation
il peut plus rien faire
imaginez-vous qui raclent à la fin du
mois vous allez tout savoir votre impôt
à la source les trois quarts des gens
vont atterrir découvrir ce qui se passe
mais vous croyez qu'il va passer sa
réforme de la retraite
vous croyez qu'il va passer les autres
réformes où il s'agit à nouveau de
mettre des coûts sociaux sur la tête des
gens venaient se qualifie donc c'est la
rue que je voulais qu'ils fassent il n'a
plus qu'une chose à faire c'est battant
que c'est au peuple de trancher
alors quand je dis ça on me dira
monsieur mélenchon h à pomper le numéro
10 mais ça ne nous profite pas mais je
m'en fous moi je suis pas là pour ça en
profite
je suis pas en train de vendée des
chaussures ou ou du papier peint je suis
en train de défendre des idées
elle avance dans le peuple tant mieux en
ce moment je 7,7 euros pour moi quand je
vois tout ce qui vient du peuple sa
confiance il ya dans le programme
l'avenir en commun donc je suis heureux
et je me disais ça avance
et alors du coup on dit avec vous êtes
infectieux mais pas du tout juste en
démocrate qui en ce moment à voir ses
idées avancées vous dites étaient en
faction en verger député de la meuse je
la plains et porte parole du groupe la
république en marche alors le groupe la
république en marche tous les gens qui
nous écoutent le sable il est présidé
par monsieur legendre qui était un
ancien journaliste voyez que ça fait 2-1
du même journal dans les sphères du
pouvoir
le journal challenges bon alors cet
homme là il est président du groupe la
république en marche et à la première
motion de censure il a dit je crois que
ce que nous faisons nous faisons trop
bien déjà tout noir tout le monde a
rigolé dans l'hémicyle tout le monde a
oublié et puis a pas longtemps elle a
recommencé en dix ans nous avons été
trop subtile trop intelligents ils sont
foutus danger n'a pas pas croyable et il
trouve que ça c'est subtil et
intelligent
ces gens sont beaux
d'arrogance et cette madame berger qui
tout d'un coup sort de sa boîte pour me
mettre en cause et vous traitez de
factieux et elle dit une chose qui vaut
rible se rend même pas compte à la
pauvre et doit pas avoir toute sa tête
quand elle mène ce genre de bataille
parce que elle met en cause deux
personnes de la france en soumises
il s'agit de 2,2 l'un est candidat sur
deux questions européennes monsieur
thomas guénolé l'autre étant est un ami
qui a été candidat pour la france
insoumise aux élections législatives et
qui est un homme qui porte ses propres
idées encore un électron libre dans la
france insoumise il fait comme il le
sent et il a dit des choses on ni l'un
ni l'autre doit appeler à l'émeute à
cassel a dit mais plus dangereux que
ceux qui cassent il ya ceux qui arme le
bras de ceux qui cassent et met en cause
nous vous rendez compte que ça veut dire
ça on peut plus parler si c'est comme ça
si il dépend de quelqu'un de dire comme
elle le fait elle que ces deux hommes
n'ont pas le droit de dire ce qu'ils ont
dit parce que je tiens à le préciser
ils n'ont pas appelé à l'émeute ils
n'ont pas appelé à tout casser
ils n'ont pas appelé à frapper à tuer
enfin ça c'est le pouvoir qui accuse
vous souvenez qu'on a entendu dire que
les légions de données pour frapper tu
es un bon ça c'est eux qui nous accusent
de ça on peut voyez je suis sympa
aujourd'hui je veux dire bon je mets ça
sur le compte de l'exagération
il sait plus très bien ce qu'ils
disaient mais quand on commence à dire
qu'on dénonce un procureur
des propos purement politique de deux
hommes qui disent
cette situation est en impasse il faut
en sortir il faut changer les
institutions médium vous dire pareil là
alors quoi faut le juger pour ça mais ça
c'est les dictatures c'est la police
politique
vous comprenez vous comptez apporter une
réponse d'une façon ou d'une autre même
peut-être
j'ai répondu ça y est on va pas non plus
monter aux rideaux tous les cinq minutes
ça fait leur jeu il faudrait que tout le
monde ses nerfs pour ne s'en portent les
noms d'oiseaux volent bon voila moi
d'amour bergère impressionné personne
jusqu'à présent dans les gilets jaunes
super-légers pas rencontré un gilet
jaune qui m'ont dit et qu'est ce qu'elle
pense madame berger de ce qu'on s'en
fout je sais faire la vérité alors
plusieurs questions dans les
commentaires en attendant quelques-uns
comme frédéric trou et on sait que vous
avez écrit une tribune en par rapport à
par rapport à eric drouhin qui fait
partie on devait expliquer pour cette
île grecque qui ne connaîtraient pas qui
est un peu une des figures du mouvement
qui a été a été interpellé le 2 janvier
dernier savait faire réagir
énormément de monde pour vous et riku et
ils symbolisent quoi bon d'abord il faut
prendre les choses avec la bonhomie
kessel de l'existence moi j'étais en
train de me reposer parce que j'ai eu un
trimestre très dur et puis bon alors
c'est la fin de l'année le 31 décembre
je vais faire un petit habillé je tiens
un blog qui est très lui c'est le
premier blog politique du pays les jean
luc mélenchon quand même je signale et
sabre mon blog
ma chaîne youtube c'est la première
chaîne youtube politique du pays et
c'est donc je sais que j'ai les moyens
de m'exprimer alors je me dis bon qu'est
ce que je pourrais faire voile nous
voilà en fin d'année il faut avoir une
petite méditation philosophique hauts
historiques sur la vie de notre pays
alors je dis bah non je trouve
extraordinaire ce pays où il ya un
drouet campêche louis saez de s'en aller
et on en a un autre aujourd'hui qui est
en train d'empêcher le monarque
présidentiel de faire ce qu'il veut et
jeux sur tout ce qui me frappe chez les
deux le drouet de 1791 et celui
d'aujourd'hui c'est que c'est des gens
qui sont des gens sans prétention je
veux dire qu'ils se sont trouvés
confrontés à des situations qu'ils y
répondent
le deux roues et de la révolution et va
passer le missel il comprend qu'il
s'enfuit donc il fait il n'attend pas
les consignes c'est une espèce
d'insoumis de son époque
il n'attend pas les consignes il sait ce
qu'il doit faire empêcher droite s'en
aller et je dis moi j'admire que
soit capable de produire comme ça des
individus qu'ils savent faire ce qu'il
faut au bon moment placé les deux noms
que j'ai retenu parce que je m'en excuse
auprès des autres c'est monsieur eric
drew et madame plessis lacs d'eau ce qui
donc le dos qui que j'ai vu j'étais un
peu écoutez et regardez ce qu'ils font
et où est il m'impressionne parce que je
les trouve très de sang froid très
mètres d'eux mêmes et surtout deux
personnages qui ont compris que s'il y
avait un alignement politique du
mouvement déchiré jaune il se rabougrir
et c'est exactement l'analyse que je
fais moi aussi moi je suis dans un le
problème suivant comment je fais pour
aider soutenir mes amis sont partout
alors c'est oui je fais là veut il ya
des insoumis surtout guerre de troie bon
il ya plein de gilet jaune a remis
dedans ils ont un coeur d'un soumis mais
on sait très bien que sur ces rien à
faire qu'il soit soumis ou ce qu'ils
veulent ce qui compte c'est ce qui se
passe est doué ou l'agglo ce qui les
deux ont l'intelligence de comprendre
qu'il faut pas rabougrir politiquement
et rabougrir ça va pas s'alourdir
laissez une organisation politique
prétendre être l'expression politique de
ce mouvement y'en a pas
ni non plus ça veut pas dire que le
mouvement lui-même devienne une
organisation politique
ça c'est un peu plus compliqué à
comprendre mais eux ils l'ont compris et
grâce à ça ils maintiennent ça j'ai
droit de dire que j'admire des gens non
quand même bon alors les autres ne les
admire personnes sont tellement
intelligents que les asnières pertes
massives
alors j'ai écrit alors vous allez voir
comment ça se passe j'ai mieux j'ai pour
une fascination les voyants fascination
toute la journée sur toutes les chaînes
d'info en continu de s'embêter des
verrines à mettre sous la dent ce jour
là mélenchon est fasciné alors ça a
commencé tout de suite ils ont rappliqué
de partout pour pour accabler ce pauvre
doué que lui même dit mais attendez moi
je comprends pas qu est ce qu on me
cherche là qu'est ce que vous voulez et
dans l'après midi on a vu tout le monde
quoi monsieur hamon est arrivé en disant
ça va chier drouet qu'à voter extrême
droite au 2e tour et c'est pas vrai pour
moi je suis là mais il a démenti et
wayne rooney a démentit pas de bol un
commis hier c'était
drouet va rencontrer le mouvement 5
étoiles en italie toute la journée
plein de gens qui me demandais comment
vous réagissez moi je réagis pas
j'attends d'abord de savoir si c'est
vrai de ce que j'ai compris la
personnalité des rideaux et je sais que
c'est pas vrai ça seul homme intelligent
et sait que s'il fait ça il clive le
mouvement il fait le cadeau que macron
rêve d'avoir
c'est à dire de donner une signification
d'extrême droite
un mouvement or ce mouvement n'est pas
d'extrême droite ni dans ses mots
d'ordre ni d'ailleurs dans sa
composition il ya des gens d'extrême
droite dans moment oui et alors et alors
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire trier tout le
monde maintenant
et bien alors on garde qui a faim qu'est
ce qui est légitime
quel est le la femme l'homme alors celui
là commune a voté de telle manière il
ramène pas il a rien à dire sur le smic
il a rien à dire sur le prix de
l'essence a l'air opté toi rentrent à la
maison non ce n'est pas possible il faut
accepter que le peuple français est fait
comme ça ce qui compte à la fin c'est
quel est le sens de l'action quels sont
les mots d'ordre sont mis en avant
et les mots d'ordre qui sont bien avant
malgré les efforts incroyables café le
pouvoir d'un côté l'extrême droite
officielle madame le pen et compagnie
sont arrivés à rien ce mouvement n'est
pas d'extrême droite qui ne voyons pas
non plus d'extrême gauche c'est un
mouvement qui pensent ses propres nous
et c'est ça qu'il faut protéger parce
que tant que c'est comme ça et ben
macron ne peut pas s'en sortir parce
qu'il sait pas par quel bout les quatre
à prétendre elle commenté alors je sais
vous étiez le 17 novembre à paris il
était présent mais certainement pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas plus présent sur le
terrain est ce que c'est la peur qu'on
vous accuse de récupération politique il
même par rapport à votre sécurité
personnelle c'est parce que sous les
cheveux
j'ai un cerveau qui me sert à réfléchir
je sais que si je vais quelque part
merci à la présence va polariser c'est à
dire que même si un haka on est à l'ère
des médias
un seul qui bien et qui dit ouais qu'est
ce que vous faites là ça m'est arrivé
une fois je vous la raconte eu à la gare
de l'est et la granny cheminots et il y
avait un poids qui était quand même bien
éméché 1 il n'avait pas sucer des
glaçons à voir
donc clairement et alors j'ai fait une
erreur de gamin
le green déjà plus quoi y'en a marre les
socialistes
moi je réponds je suis pas socialiste
bon bref vous voyez un truc tout bête
les deux se mettent à crier après moi et
là dessus il ya deux trois petits jeunes
qui sont là qui mute pas ils vous le
droit et ils ont un slogan un slogan
d'un arbre ça dit ni dieu ni maître ni
mélenchon je vous préviens je veux être
ni dieu ni leurs maîtres j'aime content
d'être mélenchon où j'essaye de faire ce
que je peux mais bon et un ils crient ça
ils ont le droit aussi
alors évidemment les caméras bon là
dessus et ça fait un incident mélenchon
- problèmes dans les manifs manif où les
gens m'aimaient beaucoup et j'espère
qu'il m'aime toujours pas ce que les
cheminots c'est du jeu en équipe gérer
relation formidable bond donc là si je
fais ça c'est ça que je risque en ainsi
donc et l'incident il servira à des
royés même mélenchon peut pas y mettre
les pieds cd bête furieuse cd
sauvagement
alors maintenant je vais vous dire la
vraie vérité de ma situation personnelle
quand je suis à la concorde le 17
novembre
j'étais avec mes marseillais qui était
monté pour venir à l'assemblée nationale
il y avait une visite qui était organisé
tout ça alors comme ces 10 militants
ayant diarra pour la manif landes où la
partie à la manif à la concorde y en
avait qui traînait leur voilier de
derrière eux enfin il faut voir le
cortège qu'on soit en viande et une
cinquantaine avec les marseillais qui
commencent à avancer alors il y avait un
gars qui est en train de démonter les
barrières vauban moi je sais pas
pourquoi je les engueule le dirai plus
de ces bon bah c'est pas la peine d'en
rajouter on va pas se battre dans la rue
et qui barrières vauban vrai bain
mélenchon qu'est ce que tu veux je fais
ce que je veux bon très bien je vais un
peu plus loin il ya des gens qui me
voient elles sont contentés pour faire
un pied de nez à maquereau l'imaginaire
et 10 mélenchon président j'ai bien
compris que c'est pas qu'ils m'aiment et
tellement qu'ils voulaient me rate c'est
juste pour embêter l'autre camp bon ben
on marre mais en même temps je me dis
hou là là ça peut être même pris tout ça
donc on a dit bon bah les amis
deux autres et c'est la première fois de
ma vie que j'ai quitté une manif parce
qu'au musée des compliments bon mais je
sais très bien que je n'ai pas intérêt à
part ma présence crée un incident mais
je peux vous dire chose puis vent dans
toutes les manifestations nous sommes
présents c'est à dire que les députés de
la région parisienne se trouve toujours
en région parisienne les députés sont la
coquerelle corbières panneaux hautain
qui est ce que j'oublie rubin j'espère
que j'ai oublié personne des députés de
le de la région parisienne et danièle
obono tout le monde est et dans les
manifs parce que c'est notre place nous
sommes les élus du peuple et moi je suis
j'étais une fois la concorde à paris une
autre fois à marseille parce qu'il y
avait trois manifs qui convergeaient les
lycéens les déloger les malheureux qui
vous savez dans les immeubles sont et se
sont effondrés ou en situation de péril
extrême et les gilet jaune plus la cgt
dont le brésilien truc pareil je peux
pas rater ça il faut que je sois là et
en plus il arrive et ce truc que dans ma
circonscription il ya deux points
d'arrivée de la manif tous très bien j
ai déjà été bien reçus gentiment mais je
veux pas créer tu voulais je veux pas
qu'on dise je veux pas qu'on m'attribue
la manifestation je sais que c'est pas
une question de gloriole personnelle ou
pas on serre la main lui aurait fait
j'ai besoin de rien je veux pas qu
rabougrissent le mouvement je voudrais
pas qu'on dise est un mouvement trans
insoumise oui il ya une influence
oui il ya beaucoup de choses en commun
mais c'est un mouvement qui appartient à
lui même
des légions sur vos listes aux
européennes c'est un souhait l'idée
belge espère qu'il ya que de ça non mais
attendez on se comprend pas là toute la
liste gilet jaune du premier au dernier
tout le monde est dans les manifs au
gilet jaune et certains vont sur les
ronds-points bien sûr puisque des sigur
du mouvement qui ne sont pas forcément
avoir premier en offre qu'elle veuille
bien parce que je sais qu'il ya trois
quatre politiciens qui ont les doigts
dans le truc là qui essayent de tirer
leurs ficelles et de se la jouer au
gilet jaune c'est pas le sens du
mouvement gilet jaune de faire une liste
aux élections européennes parce que si
on commence à discuter de cas est la
solution
pour régler le problème de l'europe dans
les gilets jaunes demain il ya plus de
mouvement parce qu'il ya autant de
points de vue que ian pearson bon j'en
suis en tout cas moi c'est ce que j'ai
compris de ce mouvement c'est à dire que
d'abord son unité ensuite est ce qu'il
ya des gilets jaunes dans la liste
insoumise oui tout le monde y en a à 79
tout le monde et gilet jaune chacun à sa
manière
est ce qui aura comme vous dites des
personnalités pour voir d'abord si elles
mêmes ont envie de l'être parce que je
n'avais pas pourquoi pour ceux qui
croient que c'est un destin incroyable
je crois vous n'avez pas bien compris ce
que c'est que d'être député européen il
est certain qu'ils ont dit clairement
bon bah bien sûr pourquoi j'y réfléchis
de pigeons je dire ils ont leur vie
d'amérique doivent ils ont aimé la voir
sur nos listes
je prépare et la rési il n'a pas voulu
mais moi je veux pas répondre à cette
question parce que je mettrais des gens
dans l'embarras le d'abord neufs qui
sont la fête
ainsi vous voulez bien ça a pris du
temps pour les six mois à temps six mois
de discussions alors et c'est pas moi
qui ai discuté avec beaucoup qui me
lécher les mains les pieds pour que je
les avants dans la liste mais non c'est
une commission de 32 personnes dont 18
tirés au sort d'accord autant d'hommes
que de femmes
donc c'est pour vous dire on a fait une
liste regardez là les gens elle est
allée publié via vous voyez les
personnalités qui a là c'est des gens il
ya dedans
un routier il ya dedans un ancien
ouvrier des abattoirs qui veut plus être
ouvrier aux abattoirs parce qu'il n'est
pas d'accord avec le ce qui s'y passe en
philosophe que benoît je déconne
burgener je sais pas je pourrais vous
citer des gens de tous les métiers
sûreté gens du peuple
il ya des personnes qui viennent du
milieu hospitalier
bon urgentistes une aide soignant tout
ça existe dans la vie c'est des gens
voilà des gens ça a pris du temps 600
candidats y avait à l'étrier là dedans
on imagine déjà les clans ça moi c'était
trop longtemps car et d'autres qui
seront en occupe moi je ne suis
intervenu cuir une chose quand on a eu
la discussion sur la tête de liste et
j'ai fait partie de ceux qui ont dit oui
il faut que la tête de liste viennent de
dieu du dob d'un mouvement de type
associatif ou syndical parce que les
deux hypothèses existent dans notre
esprit parce que ma responsabilité
aujourd'hui je m'excuse mais c'est pas
celle des autres la responsabilité de
jean luc mélenchon la responsabilité des
dix sept parlementaires insoumis et du
mouvement la france info mille c'est de
proposer au pays une alternative
donc je suis pas en train de m'occuper
de mon petit groupe à 3% pour le faire
passer à 4 1 nous sommes les plus
importants donc on assume
il faut que tout le monde puisse se
reconnaître dans cette île regardez par
exemple la présence des socialistes dans
de thé socialistes qui sont corrects en
ceux qui ont rompu avec la logique de
l'europe libérale comme monsieur morel
comme madame lienemann ces gens qui nous
ont rejoint donc lui serons la seule
liste aux européennes dans laquelle il
ya toute cette palette de gens plus pas
de carte de parti dès qu'ils en ont
d'édition des associatifs des qui
viennent de deux de la région des
douches sans union des gauches en sang
c'est vrai que les pieds de veau gens
payés vous le savez vous que le mode
d'emploi parce que union des décennies
des noës incertain dans les commentaires
qui ont regretté les difficultés on va
dire relationnel avec benoît hamon le
fait qu'ils ont une difficulté
relationnelle
je ne vais pas refaire comme je le
fréquente pas j'ai donc pas de relations
difficiles avec lui quand on a fini
l'élection présidentielle tout le monde
oublie tout moi j'étais dans les
sondages au niveau vous savez pour finir
on a fait dix neuf et demi et lui il
était dans il savait où il en était à la
fin des présidentielles m'avait vu
passer tous les jours c'est sa faute
c'est de sa faute on emprunte aux deux
noms et vous pensez la première manif
qu'on a fait mais ce que vous attendez
je vais vous répondre je vous répondrai
à tous j'ai pris l'engagement sur vous
et c'est pas parce que vous le fait
d'une manière courtoise que vous ne
coupez pas la parole pendant que c'est
très long et donc je devrais
c'est aussi la force du formage le dis
clairement pas aussi pour ceux qui l'on
regarde on essaie de mettre en place un
format des interviews où on a le temps
et je fait pour rien
j'ai pas vous aimez comme étant déjà
intéressées docteur 2h20 direct mais je
réponds ça laisse un intéressant parce
que d'un côté on va sur des sujets de
fond prend un peu de hauteur sur
l'actualité ça permet aussi pouvoir
développer avec vous et j'imagine que
ceux qui nous suivent actuellement face
à la roma je veux faire un résultat là
dessus des parents c'est une révocation
qui se passe là les gens ils s'en
rendent pas compte mais vous êtes en
train de révolutionner la manière de
faire de la formation
c'est normal c'était tout verrouiller
carré d'as et les moyens techniques
aujourd'hui les gens vous voyez pas mais
il y a un pied pour une fois d'habitude
il tient sa ans est un ancien téléphone
d'accord il fait d'habitude il un
téléphone moi je vous ai regardé je vois
comme vous faites comment vous y
prenez-vous je vois comment vous est
encore vivant lui qu'à chaque fois où
j'ai tout appris et bon bref et puis
vous avez complètement contourner tout
le système c'est à dire que les gens
tome on parle certains l'air de rien
mais c'est une révolution est ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui vous donner la parole à
un homme politique 2 hors jeu pas
qu'est-ce qui supporte deux heureux avec
moi mais bon je sais pas combien ils
sont si ça les intéresse il ya du
commentaire ou pas encore leur a fait
alors tient du coup je ne me rappelle
plus qu'elle était la question au départ
on parlait précédemment par rapport à la
gauche alors que les 1300 personnes qui
sont encore combien 8300 sur le fait
c'est bien ou pas c'est bien c'est un
oui c'est bien après c'est pas à moi
d'en juger mais lorsqu'il fait pas est
ce que sérieux aux chiffres wishart et
oui c'est intéressant vient surtout
beaucoup de gens aussi qui sont là les
commentaires qui voilà qui rêvent
beaucoup qui sont dans la réaction
pas forcément dans quelques quelques
questions pour conques le feu mais c'est
vrai qu'il y avait certains justement
qu'il parlait de l'union des gauches
justement dans le dans les commentaires
et c'est l'occasion pouvoir répondre
parce que aussi l'un des points qu'on
essaie de mettre importe qui importe en
compte dans le live c'est de mettre en
avant les commentaires et on s'excuse
pour toutes les questions qu'on aura pas
qu'on n'aurait pas pu prendre parce que
sinon on aurait fini demain matin je me
suis dis très clairement mais on essaie
en tout cas de prendre les tendances les
plus importante est celle ci en faisait
partie sur l'union dès lors il y avait
celle justement sur la présence de
gilet jaune me aref on vous y avait
répondu et sur ce côté justement l'union
des gauches ou alors sur les jets
régionaux gir et combien ces faits
j'étais un peu une allégorie je peux
dire le programme gilet jaune il est là
bon après sur quoi l'union des gauches
c'était évoqué dans certains oui oui
mais c'est bien ce que je dis tout ça
bon mois déjà commençons par le
commencement jésus rompu avec ça la
dernière élection présidentielle j'ai
dit écoutez ça n'a aucun sens qu'on
fasse semblant d'être tous d'accord
alors qu'on est d'accord sur rien
notamment sur la question européenne la
lah de parlons de l'europe a coûté ya il
ya une différence alors quitte à petit
vient de tout sur ma position 1
parce que comme je suis un bon ils sont
obligés de séné mais au départ rappelez
vous quand le g10 et il faut sortir des
traités ali faisait tous les idéaux la
com com les maquereaux nist aujourd'hui
avec les institutions ekwalla mélenchon
de sortir de rappeler qu'il faut sortir
des traités sac c est aussi cette
question qui était posée jeu rebondit
dessus votre position par rapport à l'or
il ya des gens qui pensent qu'il faut
qu'il faut arrêter l'union politique de
l'europe
c'est un point de vue moi j'ai un point
de vue un peu plus compliqué je pense
que la france est une grande puissance
et qu'on fait pas l'europe sans elle
donc si on fait une europe comme celle
qu'on a aujourd'hui sous les yeux c'est
parce que la france a laissé faire ou a
aimé que ça se passe comme ça
d'accord si on a une europe libérale
avec des traités qui interdisent
l'harmonisation fiscale qui interdisent
l'harmonisation sociale qui favorise la
lutte de chacun contre tous c'est parce
que on l'a voulu
des dirigeants politiques de droite et
des dirigeants politiques socialistes
l'ont voulu je ne sais pas une
accusation en l'air les le parti
socialiste cogère le parlement européen
avec la droite
la dernière fois ils ont fait une
campagne je le rappelle pas pour
prolonger une querelle inutilement mais
pour que tout le monde s'en souviennent
oui disait rannou plus jamais nous
voterons pour monsieur juncker
comme président de la commission
voiliers qui est monsieur jones pas bon
c'est l'ancien premier ministre du
luxembourg qui a passé des années à
organiser un système massif de
détournement des ciels et chaussures des
entreprises pour payer moins d'impôts au
luxembourg bref un personnage il ya de
droite puis ça va on a compris il s'en
cache pas eh bien les socialistes cogère
avec
et le coeur de l'europe qui est en
allemagne je le rappelle le gouvernement
allemand est composée de gens de droite
et nos membres du parti socialiste c'est
pas une petite question c'est pas une
difficulté relationnelle
non c'est une question de fond il faut
rompre avec ça bon donc moi j'ai fait
mon choix et j'en avais assez du boogie
boucle à eau fait semblant pour celle de
tous alors ils ont fait étape réunion où
une primaires de toute la gauche à la
fin certains étaient au gouvernement
d'autres qui étaient pas de capharnaüm
incroyable tout ça c'est terminé quand
vous le savez moi j'ai une
responsabilité je vais pas embarquer
tout le monde dans des aventures
politicienne sans issue qu'est-ce que
vous voulez que je je m'accorde
aujourd'hui avec le parti socialiste de
monsieur faure qui passe son temps à
expliquer par tous premièrement que
comme c'est là tout va bien on europe 1
qu'il faut continuer bla bla bla bla et
deuxièmement que monsieur mélenchon
étant factieux je sais pas quoi dire non
même pas la modestie de se dire écoutez
on s'est pris une telle tall que
finalement on va réfléchir vous rappeler
à un moment donné et moi j'ai fait une
proposition
je suis allé à libération qui est
l'organe central de la social démocratie
en france pour je dis ça sans sans
aucune mauvaise intention non pas cette
gauche-là ce centre gauche se retrouvent
plutôt l'adorable centre-droit dans le
monde
la libération les centre-gauche et les
bons je suis là-bas immo qui nous
donnait deux pages
on s'est expliqué longuement et je leur
ai dit ben nous pouvons faire un front
populaire
si l'objectif c'est bien de fédérer le
peuple c'est à dire de partir des
revendications populaires et de leur
donner une réponse par d'aller voir le
peuple pour lui dire et maintenant on va
vous expliquer pourquoi faut encore
continuer à manger de 7 euros plein dont
vous ne voulez plus je ne veux pas
parler plus simplement du sujet donc
j'ai fait une proposition qu'elle a été
la réponse des insultes et une
ostracisation une quand il parle de moi
on a l'impression qu'on parle d'une bête
féroce de quelqu'un à qui personne ne
veut partage de ces histoires n'ont
alors là je vois comment fait-on une
liste quant à quel moment
de quoi on parle sur quel programme et
d'ailleurs je m'oriente j'étais franc du
collier j'ai dit au départ faudra faire
ça marche
mais ce qu'il faut c'est une halle est
honnête avec un programme honnêtes
claires et puis bah quoi mettons nous en
aux électeurs et tous ceux qui venaient
jusque là me chanter la chanson de
l'unité qu'est ce que je voyais supporte
pas entre eux donc même s'il dit et si
importante dès qu'ils commencent qu'il
la fasse entre eux mais ils ne sont même
pas capables de ça alors
ce qui au début que veut europe ecologie
les verts parlé d'unité pour finir n'en
veulent pas monsieur hamon ne veut pas
s'allier avec le parti socialiste il
vient de répondre et c'est à moi qu'on
vient régulièrement dire est ce que vous
voulez une ondée gauche union de qui je
ne comprends même plus et surtout il ya
une chose qui est pas possible
vous verrez nous on n'a jamais répondu
au niveau de violence aux attaques sont
portées contre eux et singulièrement
contre moi ou personne
encore aujourd'hui ce pauvre monsieur
faure tout ce qu'il a trouvé à faire
c'est de dire dire je sais plus dans
quel mois un bref insupportable dérive
de jean luc mélenchon vers les rouge
brun rouge brun est ce que est ce que
cet homme se rend compte du moût est ce
qu il croit que ça va lui rapporter une
voiture ça non que ça peut faire c'est
que ça peut décourager des gens qui se
disent ah mon dieu
ah bon c'est ça bon quand puisque c'est
comme ça je t'ai rien donc je m'abstiens
et chaque instant sion ça finira par
servir le pouvoir veut c'est bien donc
moi j'attends que tout ce monde là
deviennent plus claires sur ses
objectifs et sur sa politique je me
serve que tout le monde progressivement
au moins en paroles bien sûr ma position
la sortie des traités parce que ces
traités ne permettent pas de faire
fonctionner une union avec le sérieuse
avec l'objectif qu'on doit avoir qui est
le progrès social alors moi j'ai donné
ma position plan à
si je suis le président de la république
si par l'élection européenne
je dirais moi çà çà çà çà c'est fini
retraités beau et remballer et comme on
ne peut pas faire je leur dirai pourquoi
parce que ça a provoqué la catastrophe
en grèce en espagne au portugal parce
que les anglais ont fini par fiche le
camp parce que chez nous les gens
peuvent plus cette politique d'accords
donc store on fait autre chose vous
voulez pas faire autre chose ben on
regardera si vous voulez pas nous on est
prêt les français à faire autre chose on
est prêt à faire une union
d'harmonisation sociale d'harmonisation
fiscale avec un plan de conversion de
transition énergétique et vous
deux questions parce que vous y répondez
déjà indirectement alors déjà il ya ce
grand débat qui va commencer dans les
prochains jours est ce que vous y êtes
favorable ou non et deuxième question
tout simplement plus générale portait
sur l'avenir aussi vous avez commencé il
raconte d'un point de vue européen
mais comment on sort de cette crise
comment faire en sorte de selon vous si
gilet jaune qui prépare l'acte neuf qui
va se dérouler samedi un peu partout
j'espère que ça sera un très grand
succès puis j'invite mes et commencent à
les insoumis et les gens qui ont
confiance en moi serait sont errants
vous bah moi je vais être là où je peux
être utile donc vous savez une fois j'ai
répondu oui comme ça à une émission de
télé pas fait attention mon jeu c'était
devenu une information résultat peut
plus aller nulle part
donc je suis allé à marseille il faisait
pour quelle raison elle est ce que c'est
possible de vous voir samedi
il veut ceux qui seront autour de veron
mais pas plus parce que si je vais
quelque part et je l'annoncerai veut
dire des caméras donc des malheureux qui
pattes des risques mais sur le terrain
mais en discrétion je pense que ont bien
pas moi je verrais mais on verra pas
comment comment comment sortir comment
éviter que ça continue encore pendant
des mois qu'elle quelle solution
politique aujourd'hui apportées à ces
gilet jaune qui sont justement qui
certains nous regardent prudemment parmi
ceux qui auraient vous allez rire se
lève qui disent bon ben may well et
cherchons pas le niveau d'exigence monte
il faut faire donc d'abord commençons
par dire que des blancs pour contre non
mais moi je nomme je le débat je vais
vous répondre mais je m'étais déjà d'en
rendre mou
je suis du côté des gilet jaune ne pas
faire semblant d'être dans les nuages
donc de ce côté là je dis faisons très
attention à ce que nos adversaires
essaye de faire c'est-à-dire de
marginaliser de pousser à la faute
enfin bon les responsables
ce sont toujours magnifiquement sortie
de toutes les situations mais en tout
cas il faut les submergés par le nombre
donc moi je sais que samedi à j'espère
qu'il y aura du monde partout partout
partout beaucoup plus vous serez
nombreux plus l'horizon la violence
bêche et plus le pouvoir sera en quelque
sorte contraint d'admettre que qu'est-ce
qu'il va pas voir aujourd'hui doit faire
quoi il faire comme étant des mois je
vais pas expliquer à monsieur maxence
qui doit faire je peux expliquer ce que
moi je pleurais et votre avion dès que
je commence à avoir sur le débat pain
vous réponds sur le débat c'est une
comédie parce que l'on gère tout parti
de travers la présidente est plus
présidente les maires y en a un paquet
qui disons mais nous pour qu'on va
organiser un truc pareil
et puis tout à l'heure j'ai fait un
petit lapsus en rencontre on était en
train de parler d'europe
et vous êtes passés au débat et parce
que je pense que dans votre esprit vous
vous souvenez qui a déjà eu un débat
dans ce pays
et qu'est-ce que les gens vous en
rappelez pas même s'il y en a déjà eu en
effet un débat parce que vous parlez
sous le g20 auront avait proposé qu'il
ya un grand débat sur l'europe pour
trouver les solutions d'avenir pour
l'europe et c'est vous en rappelez il
est même le relais dans toute l'europe
il a eu en france élus des petites
réunions confidentielles aux frais de
l'état pour faire la campagne européenne
des macros nist il ne s'est rien passé
et donc quand vous avez un mouvement
d'une puissance pareil
la réponse c'est les gens n'ont pas un
grand débat il devant nous que des
réponses concrètes soient apportées à
leurs peuples
premier problème comment rendre la vie
des gens mots durs
comment faire que les petites paye soit
dépaysée sentent qu'on va faire que les
minimas sociaux permettent de vivre et
ainsi de suite première grande question
deuxième grande question
ce système ne fonctionne pas et ce blog
continuellement
donc il faut changer la règle du jeu
politique c'est ce que les gens
proposent avec le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne et que ce que moi
je propose c'est une assemblée citoyenne
constituante soir unies dans ce pays
plus le temps passe plus monsieur macron
pense qu'il va s'en sortir sans rien
faire plus le niveau d'exigence monte et
ce que je ne voudrais pas c'est qu'à la
fin les gens se regardent en chiens de
faïence
parce qu'au fond dans ce pays on
pourrait trouver une grande majorité
pour avoir une assemblée en titre
dans ce pays on pourrait avoir une
majorité pour rétablir l'impôt sur la
fortune et créer 14 tranche d'impôt on
pourrait trouver ça un ne le fera pas
ils ne veulent pas le faire parce qu'ils
ne veulent pas partager
voilà eh bien je pense que tant qu'on
restera dans cette tension sera paralysé
évidemment le niveau d'exigence
populaire va va remonter donc si le
président de la république et le premier
ministre dix est ce que je vais dire ah
je n'ai pas forcément ma faveur 10
d'écouté nous ne voulons pas changer de
position parce que nous estimons que
nous avons été élus pour faire cette
politique
d'accord vous la détestez mais on a été
élu pour ça et puis les autres disent
bas nous nous ne voulons pas que vous
l'appliquez alors mon vote
c'est pourquoi je pense d'ailleurs que
plus le temps passe plus c'est l'impasse
et plus ou va en direction de la
dissolution c'est d'ailleurs à quoi le
pouvoir se prépare il fait monter les
tensions il essaye de faire vous savez
deux crans les afro les méchants les
abominables
et puis les gentils qui doit se
retrouver tous ensemble autour de
monsieur mâcon ça commence à sentir la
campagne électorale ça commence déjà à
sentir la campagne électorale et puis le
ils ont décidé de faire une
manifestation de tous ceux qui sont
partisans du président matheron et il va
le jouer un peu le numéro à la de gaulle
mais n'est pas de gaulle qui veut dire
la grosse manifestation et puis derrière
nous verrons mais 71 25 ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il faut à chaque jour
suffit sa peine
là nous avons une tâche à accomplir il
faut que la mobilisation soit son plus
haut niveau samedi
moi je ne peux rien faire d'autre que de
dire il faut que ça soit son plus haut
niveau possible est bon et puis on verra
samedi
ce qu'il faut faire mais je ne dis au
pouvoir politique
si vous croyez qu'il suffit de faire de
la répression de punir des gens très
durement et de me montrer moi comme le
diable et que vous croyez que c'est
comme ça que vous allez régler un
problème politique pareil vous trompez
vous ne comprenez pas ce qu'est la
france et vous commettez une très grande
erreur en repoussant des gens quand vous
dit
n'appartient plus au camp républicain
c'est vous qui d'une manière ou d'une
autre
messieurs dames les maquereaux nist vous
mettez à côté de la république parce que
le fondamental de la république c'est le
peuple
il faut jamais oublier ça il ya 15 ans
dans ce pays le peuple alors bien sûr
des fois ses intentions sont difficiles
à connaître l on vote
alors j'en profite pour ce qui est
qu'ils n'ont rien parce que certains ne
me pose une question directement en
demandant si on a sollicité d'autres
personnalités politiques
profitez en bien sûr énormément d'autres
et on a eu un accord pour une interview
demain avec le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner qui sera notre
invité sur bruche demain à 14 heures
alors moi j'aimerais vous dire jean luc
mélenchon s'il y avait une question à
poser à christophe castaner ce serait
laquelle
mais l'enjeu le jeu bordelais d'accord
j'ai promis donc je répondrais aussi à
ça
castaner et moi on a quelque chose en
commun à part d'être début juin qu'il ne
savait pas quoi vous dire
il ya des types qui ont décidé de nous
tuer lui et moi lui voulait l'égorger -
vol entre carence flammes le chef de
cette bande a été arrêté le 28 mai 2010
est élu ne vaut 100 comédiens dire nir
castaner non plus ce que j'en ai parlé
avec lui et les neuf autres ont été
arrêtés en octobre depuis un à quatre
qui ont été libérés au bout de huit mois
je crois de prison préventive alors là
où ils sont d'accord ça les a pas trop
émulant la république en marche depuis
je continue à être un homme qui se
protège par lui même
donc monsieur castaner a eu du mal à
admettre qu'il y avait une violence de
l'ultra droite qui existent dans le pays
et je le lui redit comme ministre de
l'intérieur il n'est pas normal que des
gens est occupé un col soit venu avec un
hélicoptère pour empêcher des gens de
passer soit disant la frontière il sera
donc en quelque sorte substituer à
l'état
ce n'est pas normal ce n'est pas normal
qu'ils aient lieu des violences comme
celles qu'on peut constater dans une
série de villes ou des petites bandes de
cette nature font peur alors bon